GOOD MORNING.
DOCTOR RICHARD AND.
AND.
WANNA.
CALL TO ORDER THIS I JOIN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEES ON THE CENSUS.
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS AND WELL
WELCOME EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE
TODAY.
AND I THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
INTEREST IN AND THE CENSUS.
SO THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY
JOINT HEARINGS. WITH THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEES
OF THE CENSUS.
SURE THAT YOU ALL HAVE.
COMMON CENSUS.
BUT I'M PUMP IT UP PUMP ALRIGHT.
BUT WE STILL
THAT ARE ALL AWARE OF HOW
CRITICAL THE CENSUS IS THE
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M SURE YOU HAVE MANY OF
YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR THESE
NUMBERS BUT I THINK ILLUSTRATES
THAT THE PICTURE.
WELL.
FOR EVERY PERSON UNDERCOUNTED
CALIFORNIA LOSES TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PERSON PER YEAR.
AND FACT INTO ANY FIFTEEN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED ABOUT
SEVENTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS AND
FEDERAL FUNDS BASED OFF THE
POPULATION COUNT.
FUNDS THAT WENT TO HEALTH CARE
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION OTHER.
SERVICES.
SO TEMPORE THAT EVERYONE
DISCOUNTED NOT ONLY FOR THE
FINANCIAL SECURITY BUT ALSO THAT
SHARED A PLACE IN HISTORY.
TODAY WE HOPE TO GET AN OVERVIEW
OF THE CENSUS AND THE DIFFERENT
ROLES EVERYONE PLACE AND HELP
ENSURE AND ACCURATE COMPLETE
COUNT.
THIS UPCOMING CENSUS WILL BE
PARTICULARLY MORE CHALLENGING
IN PREVIOUS YEARS SO WE WANT TO
GET A BETTER SENSE OF HOW WE
COMPARE FOR THOSE BEARS IN
ADVANCE.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS MUCH MORE
THAT NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF TODAY'S
HEARING BUT THIS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING.
I'LL WE HAVE A GREAT LINE UP FOR
YOU TODAY WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM ANY EXPERIENCE A
KNOWLEDGEABLE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
ENGAGED IN PAST CENSUSES ARE
PREPARING FOR THE ONE AHEAD.
THEY WILL SHARE THEIR LESSONS
BEST PRACTICES IN WAYS WE CAN'T
PARRIS SELVES WERE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS AND WHAT THINK ALL OUR
SPEAKERS FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF.
YOUR BUSY SCHEDULES AND EVEN
TRAVELING TO BE WITH US HERE
TODAY. ALSO I THINK MY CO CHAIR
SO THEIR BERMAN AND HIS STAFF
ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH MINE
TO MAKE SURE. TO MAKE THIS YEAR
IMPOSSIBLE I ALSO WANT TO THANK.
ARE SENATE PRO TEM.
TONI ATKINS OR STAFF THE SENATE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK AND SUPPORT AS WELL.
SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH IS
KIND OF TO BRING YOU THE
BACKGROUND PAPER.
I JUST A FEW REMINDERS BEFORE I
PASS IT OVER TO MY CO CHAIR OUT
PLEASE.
KEEP TIGHT COMMENTS OF TIMES
PREVIOUSLY WORKED OUT STAFF OF
MY TIMER HERE.
ALSO PUT NOTIFIED HOW MUCH TIME
YOU HAVE SO SO DON'T PLEASE
PLEASE DON'T FORGET TO LOOK UP.
AFTER EACH PANEL WILL GO INTO A
QUEUE IN A PORTION WHICH WILL
NOT BE TIME TO ALLOW FOR IT LAOS
GO INTO MORE DETAILS OF THE
ISSUES THAT I'VE BEEN BROUGHT UP.
AND THEY MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
FULLY COVER YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS.
ALL THE POWER POINT
PRESENTATIONS AND DOCUMENTS YOU
SEE TODAY WILL BE AVAILABLE ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE WEBSITES.
GO AGAIN.
Y. THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE AND I NOW INVITE MY CO
CHAIR SOMEWHERE BERMAN TO MAKE
HIS OPENING REMARKS WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH DOCTOR PAN.
THEN THINK YOU EVER WANT IT TO
COMING TO PARTICIPATE IS AS
SPEAKER IS.
JUST TO LISTEN TO TODAY'S
TESTIMONY I COULD BE MORE
EXCITED ABOUT THAT OUR JOINT.
HEARING OF OUR BOTH BOTH OF OUR
THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEES ON THE CENSUS.
ABOUT USUALLY WHEN YOU CREATE A
SELECT COMMITTEE OF THE BAG YOUR
COLLEAGUES TO PARTICIPATE. AND
THIS TIME WE ACTUALLY TO TURN
PEOPLE AWAY AT LEAST ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE THERE ARE MORE
PEOPLE THAT WANT TO PARTICIPATE.
THAN WE HAD SLOTS AND I
ACTUALLY HAD TO GO ASK THE
SPEAKER FOR GETTING CHRIS THE
NUMBER OF SPOTS ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE TO WHICH SHE E. SAID
NO. WHICH IT WAS THE RIGHT
ANSWER THINK TO KEEP IT SMALL
AND AND SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
GET GOOD WORK DONE BUT I THINK
THAT'S JUST AN INDICATION OF HOW
MUCH INTEREST THERE IS MUCH
ANXIETY THERE IS.
AROUND THE CENSUS BOTH IN THE
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES BACK HOME
SO THE SELECT COMMITTEES ARE
GONNA PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE.
IN.
BRINGING INFORMATION UP FROM ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS THAT WE CAN
THEN PASS ON TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
AND THE STATE.
COMPLETE COUNTS COMMITTEE AND
ALSO.
KEEPING TRACK OF THE EFFORTS OF
THE COMPLETE
ACCOUNT COMMITTEE MISTAKENLY CAO
COMMITTEE AND AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE NECESSARY FUNDING. TO.
CONDUCT A ROBUST OUR REGION
COMMUNICATION EFFORT.
IN ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE.
WE ALWAYS HAVE AN UNDERCOUNT IN
THE CENSUS THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
BEEN A HISTORIC THING CALIFORNIA
UNDER CAO IF SOME THE MOST YEAH
HARD TO COUNT COUNTIES IN THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING. LA COUNTY
WHICH IS THE HARDEST ACCOUNT
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY BUT THINGS
ARE A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT
NOW.
WITH THE ANXIETY AND FEAR IN
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
AROUND THAT EFFORTS THAT ARE
BEING UNDERTAKEN BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT THAT WE TRIPLE OUR
EFFORTS THAT WERE IS COORDINATED
AS POSSIBLE THAT WE GET. EXPERTS
TO COME IN AND GIVE US ADVICE ON
PAST PRACTICE WHAT WORKED AND
WHAT HASN'T OF AND WE'RE GONNA
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA GETS COUNTED EVERY
EVERY RESIDENT. IN CALIFORNIA
GETS COUNTED.
SO WITH THAT I'LL INTRODUCE.
ARE OPEN OUR FIRST GUEST.
WERE ESPECIALLY HONORED TO
WELCOME FORMER CENSUS DIRECTOR
VINCE BERAPA. TO OPEN THIS JOINT
SPECIAL HEARING ON PREPARING FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
I CANNOT THINK OF ANYONE WITH
MORE EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE IN
THIS FIELD WHO WANTS TODAY'S
DISCUSSIONS.
DIRECTOR BROUGH HAS COMPILED A
LONG AND ILLUSTRIOUS CAREER
SERVING A VARIETY OF BUSINESS
POLITICAL AND PUBLIC SERVICE
POSITIONS.
FOR OUR PURPOSES TODAY IT IS HIS
DISTINCTION OF RECEIVING
APPOINTMENTS BY PRESIDENTS OF
DIFFERENT PARTIES TO THE
POSITION OF DIRECTOR OF U. S.
BUREAU OF THE CENSUS. DURING
WHICH TIME HE PRESIDED OVER THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY CENSUS SOME OF
YOU MAY ALSO KNOWN AS A MEMBER
OF CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION WHETHER
TWENTY TEN CENSUS DATA WAS THE
FOUNDATION OF ITS DECISION
MAKING. ITS MY SPECIAL PLEASURE
TO INVITE DIRECTOR OF VINCE
BRAVO TO SHARE HIS WEALTH OF
INSIGHTS WITH US TODAY THANKS SO
MUCH MAKE YOU.
YOU HAVE IRA HEADFIRST SLIDE
GAVE THE.
.
NOT THAT MY PERSONAL HISTORY THE
BUREAU I'VE I WAS THE USER.
AND MY WIFE MADE MIGHT BE MAKE
IT VERY HOUSE THE USER OF CENSUS
DATA NOT USER OF ANYTHING ELSE
THAT.
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR DO I
SEVENTY TWO BECAUSE I DID THEY
HAVE.
A LOT OF POLITICAL CAMPAIGN
WORKING HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
I PM A PUSHER AYE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE AND SEVENTY SIX
AND SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY ONE. AS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CENSUS
BUREAU.
THE PUSH YOUR YET AGAIN OF FACT
THIS DATA HAD THAT.
AND THE GUY AND THEN I BECAME A
USER AGAIN I BECAME ADDICTED.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY HIGH TO TWO
THOUSAND TEN.
THAT WE WERE INVOLVED WITH
THEY'VE BUSINESS THAT STRATEGIES
IN FOR LARGE CORPORATIONS.
THEN IN TWO THOUSAND TEN. AT ANY
KILL NOW I WAS A COMMISSIONER ON
THE CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION.
BUT SADLY THE TWO QUESTIONS THAT
DATA THAT WERE AND THAT WAS ASSN
THAT WAS THE. HISTORICAL CONTEXT
OF REGARDING THE CENSUS.
AND.
Y. DEFENSE IS IMPORTANT FOR
WHAT SHE IS STILL. LET ME START
WITH THE FIRST TWO.
NEXT LIGHT DERRIERE.
I KNOW YOU CAN'T BE DEBT SO I
HAVE TO READ IT TO YOU.
SO EVEN COUNTY OUR ENTIRE ENTIRE
POPULATION AND USING THE CENSUS
OF INHABITANTS.
NOT CITIZENS BUT INHABITANTS
FOR A LONG TIME THIS LETTER CAME
FROM THE POSTMASTER GENERAL.
WRITTEN IN SEVENTEEN NINETY
THREE.
IT SERVES AS AN EXAMPLE
IF THERE BE ANY SPARE COPIES OF
THE CENSUS OF INHABITANTS OF THE
STATE'S.
IN THE OFFICE OF THE SECRETARY
OF STATE.
THE POSTMASTER GENERAL REQUEST
MISTER JEFFERSON TO FAVOR HIM
WITH ONE.
IT BEING PROPER TO ATTEND TO THE
POPULATION OF THE COUNTRY. IN
FORMING AN OPINION UPON THE
APPLICATION OF NEW POSTSCRIPT.
THAT WAS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE SEVENTEEN NINETY THREE.
SO ADDITION ALLOCATING SEATS IN
CONGRESS WE EVEN HAVE LITTLE
EFFECT ON HER POST OFFICE.
BRINKLEY.
FIXED THERE.
SO MAKING SURE EVERYONE IS
COUNTED IS REALLY A VERY
DIFFICULT TASK CRITICALLY AS IT
RELATES TO HARD TO REACH
POPULATIONS.
THAT AS WELL AS THOSE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THE
INFORMATION WILL BE USED.
AND I'M GLAD THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND IN THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
UNDERTAKEN AN OUTREACH TO AND
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
TO HELP THE SENSE THAT SIXTY.
I'VE HAD TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
THE REACHING OUT AND
COMMUNICATING WITH WITH HARD TO
COUNT COMMUNITIES.
BOTH TIMES THAT I RAN THE
SENATE THAT'S NEW HERE'S WHAT WE
DID IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WE
CREATED THE FIRST MINORITY
STATUS ADVISORY COMMITTEES.
PRIOR TO DOING SO JACK INGRAM
ONE OF THE BUREAUS AFRICAN
AMERICANS SUGGESTED TO ME THAT
IF WE DON'T GET THE RIGHT PEOPLE
TO PARTICIPATE.
THE IMPACT OF THE COMMITTEES ON
THE COMMUNITIES WE WANT TO REACH
OUT TO. WOULD BE OF LITTLE VALUE.
WE STARTED THIS EFFORT BY
REACHING OUT TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
THE FIRST PERSON WE ASKED TO
JOIN THE COMMITTEE WAS BOBBY
SEALE.
OF THE BLACK PANTHERS.
BUT FIRST WE HAD TO LOCATED.
WHICH PROVED TO BE QUITE A TASK.
WE EVENTUALLY REACHED HIM
THROUGH FIVE INTERMEDIARIES.
AND ONCE HE AGREED TO ATTEND A
MEETING DEFORMED THE COMMITTEE.
WE MANAGED TO BRING TOGETHER A
VERY REPRESENTATIVE GROUP OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS
COVERING THE FULL RANGE OF
PERSPECTIVES.
FROM THE AND DOUBLE ACP TO THE
URBAN LEAGUE STILL RIGHTS
ACTIVISTS.
AND ACADEMICS.
NEXT I.
WHEN YOU'RE CREATING AN OUTREACH
PROGRAMS TO BE SURE YOU'RE
IDENTIFYING REAL COMMUNITY
LEADERS WHO CAN CARRY THE
MESSAGE.
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SENSES TO THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
LET ME TELL YOU A STORY.
AB DULY OUT SHIP OZ WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST MEMBERS OF THE BLACK
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR SURVIVES PARTICIPATED
ACTIVELY AND ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
BARRY MEMBER HIM MOST.
FOR HOW HE INTENTLY LISTEN TO
BOTH SIDES OF ANY DISCUSSION.
AND WHEN HE SPOKE IT WAS NO
QUESTION HIT.
THOUGHT THROUGH EVERY WORD.
I WOULD APPRECIATE HOW WELL HE
WAS LISTENING WHEN WE TURN TO
THE SET WHEN I RETURNED THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
THAT YEAR HE ARRANGED FOR ME TO
VISIT WITH WALLACE DEAN MUHAMMAD.
AT THE MUSLIM MOSQUE IN CHICAGO
SENT OUTSIDE.
HERE'S MY TWO OF MY COUSINS
CHICAGO IS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
THE SOUTH SIDE AND STONE UP. BUT
WE WENT.
AND.
WHEN WE ARRIVED I WAS ESCORTED
INTO THE MASKING WITHIN MINUTES
IMAM MUHAMMAD AWRY.
I PLAN TO PRESENT HIM WITH THE
REASONING BEHIND OUR REQUEST FOR
THE MONTH SINCE THE COMMUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE EIGHTY CENTS
IS REVERSING THEIR DECISION. NOT
TO PARTICIPATE.
AS THEY HAD IN NINETEEN SEVENTY.
BEFORE I COULD START.
IMAM MUHAMMAD BEGAN THE
DISCUSSION BY POINTING OUT.
THAT HE HAD RECEIVED A VERY
POSITIVE REPORT.
AND OUR PROCEDURES AND OUR
INTENT FROM DOCTOR ZHIVAGO.
IN HE HAD DIRECTED HIS
LEADERSHIP CAME TO COMMUNICATE
TO THE MEMBERSHIP. THAT THE
MUSLIM COMMUNITY SHOULD
PARTICIPATE.
HE POINTED OUT THAT WOULD USE
THE MUSLIM SCHOOL SYSTEM AS THE
PRIMARY SOURCE OF COMMUNICATION.
THE WHOLE MEETING TOOK ABOUT
FIVE MINUTES.
IT WAS CLEAR REALIZE THAT DOCTOR
SHE ADVISED HIM NOT ONLY LISTEN
WELL.
BUT IT TAKEN FULL MEASURE OF
WHAT WAS SAID.
AND PROMISED BY THE CENSUS
BUREAU AND THEN CONVEYED HIS
REASON.
A REASONABLE POINT OF VIEW TO
THE MUSLIM LEADERSHIP.
JACK INGRAM WAS RIGHT WHEN HE
SAID IT WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT
WE GET PEOPLE ON THE COMMITTEE
WITH CREDIBLE REPUTATIONS.
HE MUST'VE BEEN THINKING OF
PEOPLE LIKE DR SHABAZZ.
IT AND ITS MY ADVICE THAT IT ALL
OF CALIFORNIA CENTER THOUGHT
REACH.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU FIVE
MAY DR SHABAZZ'S AS YOU POSSIBLY
CAN.
NOW. THE NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
IN THIS THAT MESSAGE OUT.
ROBERT MERTON MAKES THE
OBSERVATION AND SERVICES THE
POTENTIAL. THAT ONE INCORRECT
SITUATIONS ARE PERCEIVED BY
PEOPLE AS REAL.
THEY ARE REAL IN THEIR
CONSEQUENCES.
SO TODAY IF US CITIZENS THOSE
WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY. ARE FROM
MINORITY GROUPS PROCEED PIXIE
THAT THE CLAIM. THAT BY FILLING
OUT THE CENSUS FORM THEY WILL BE
PLACING THEMSELVES IN DANGER.
THEY WILL BE LESS LIKELY TO FILL
OUT THE FORM AND THEREFORE NOT
BE COUNTED. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A REAL
DANGER OF PEOPLE NOT FILLING OUT
THE CENSUS FORM.
AND THAT'S WHY SPENDING MONEY ON
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
IN CALIFORNIA IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
IN THIS CASE THE PERCEPTION OF
POSSIBLE DIRECT HARM. BY FILLING
OUT THE FORM IS NOT CORRECT.
IT'S NOT CORRECT BECAUSE IT IS
AGAINST THE LAW OF TITLE
THIRTEEN OF U. S. CARD.
FOR ANY CENSUS BUREAU EMPLOYEE
TO DISCLOSE OR PUBLISH ANY SENSE
IT'S OUR SURVEY INFORMATION.
THAT IDENTIFIES THE INDIVIDUAL
OR BUSINESS.
SO ALTHOUGH I STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THE CITIZENSHIP QUESTION
SHOULD NOT BE ADDED TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
IF IT IS ADDED. IS IMPORTANT TO
CORRECTIVE PERCEPTION THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS INFORMATION WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO OTHER AGENCIES OF
GOVERNMENT.
WHO MIGHT CAUSE THEM HARM? AND
ENCOURAGE ALL INHABITANTS OF THE
UNITED STATES TO STAND UP AND BE
COUNTED.
THE STATE WILL NEED A PROGRAM TO
GET THE WORD OUT ABOUT TITLE
THIRTEEN.
AND BE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT TITLE THIRTEEN
PROTECTS THEM.
FOR THEY WILL BE COUNTED AND I
WILL NOW PROVIDE TWO EXAMPLES.
BASED ON MY OWN EXPERIENCE.
HE DEMONSTRATE THE EXTENT TO
WHICH A SENSE THE PEROT.
CAN KEEP ITS PROMISE.
AND WEDNESDAY AUGUST THIRTEENTH
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR FBI AGENTS
ARRIVED THAT THE DISTRICT OFFICE
IN COLORADO SPRINGS.
ARMED WITH A SEARCH WARRANT.
BUT THE WRITING THEM TO SEIZE
SENSES DOCUMENTS.
INCLUDING COMPLETED
QUESTIONNAIRES.
IN THE COURSE OF THEIR
LEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION. OF A
CASE INVOLVING ALLEGED
QUESTIONNAIRE FALSIFICATION.
AND PAYROLL FRAUD.
I WAS IMMEDIATELY INFORMED OF
THE SITUATION.
RECOGNIZE THE POTENTIALLY
DISASTROUS SITUATION WHICH BOTH
THE FBI.
AND THE AND THE CENSUS BUREAU
HAVE HAD STUMBLED ON.
AND I'VE REACHED THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI WITH HAVING.
DINNER AT A RESTAURANT.
AFTER SEVERAL TELEPHONE CALLS TO
EMPLOYEES IN COLORADO.
WE AGREED A SATISFACTORY
CONCLUSION.
THAT ALLOW THE FBI TO PROCEED
WHILE THE DISPUTED QUESTIONS
REMAIN. IN THE CUSTODY OF THE
CENSUS BUREAU.
ULTIMATELY THE DOCUMENTS REPLACE
IN A SECURE ROOM PROTECTED BY
TWO LOCKS.
WHEN HE HELD BY THE FBI AND THE
OTHER BY LOCAL CENSUS OFFICIALS.
UNDER THIS ARRANGEMENT ONLY
SWORN CENSUS EMPLOYEES WERE
ALLOWED TO ENTER THE ROOM.
BUT AN FBI AGENT HAD TO BE
PRESENT WHEN THE DOOR WAS OPEN
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT APPROPRIATE PEOPLE ENTERED.
WHEN THE DOOR WAS LOCKED IN
AGENT WAS THAT STATIONED OUTSIDE
THE ROOM TO MAKE SURE
UNAUTHORIZED PERSONNEL. DID NOT
ENTER THE ROOM.
THE CENSUS BUREAU BROUGHT THAT
IN HAY.
EXPERIENCE ENUMERATOR SOME
OUTSIDE OF THE DENVER AREA.
TO RE INTERVIEW THE RESPONDENTS
IN THE AREA WHERE THEY ALLEGE
FRAUD HAD TAKEN PLACE.
AND THEY DID A HEY WE CAMPUS OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND THEN
COMPARED THAT THE CAMPUS TO THE.
.
BUT WAS SAID BROUGHT IN AS A
PROBLEM IDEA.
I THE FBI.
AND IT WAS ALL RESOLVED.
UNDER TITLE THIRTEEN EVEN THE
ADDRESS LIST USED TO BE OF THE
SENSES ARE CONFIDENTIAL.
IN THE LITIGATION THAT FOLLOWED
THE NINETEEN EIGHTY CENSUS THE
CITY OF NEW YORK.
OBTAINED A DISTRICT COURT ORDER
REQUIRING THE CENSUS BUREAU HAS
TURNED OVER ITS ADDRESS
REGISTERS FOR THE CITY. SO THAT
LOCAL OFFICIALS MIGHT COMPARE
THE LISTINGS WITH THEIR OWN
RECORDS.
BECAUSE OF THE LAWSUIT.
WE WERE UNDER A COURT ORDER NOT
TO DELIVER THE CENSUS RESULTS TO
THE PRESIDENT.
THANKS THE JUSTICE THURGOOD
MARSHALL.
I RECEIVED A PHONE CALL LATE THE
EVENING OF DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
INDICATING THE JUSTICE IT STAY
THE RULING.
AND THE NEXT MORNING THE
SECRETARY OF COMMERCE AND I
FORWARDED THE CENSUS RESULTS
PRESIDENT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO THE CASE
WITHOUT ME REACHED THE US
SUPREME COURT.
SHE CITED IN THE CENSUS BUREAU'S
FAVOR.
ADDRESS LIST COULD NOT BE
DISCLOSED HERE TO SETTLE CIVIL
DISCUSS FOR DISCOVERY.
ARE UNDER THE FREEDOM OF
INFORMATION ACT.
I FELT A FEW MORE MINUTES AND I.
DEPENDING AT TIME MAKE IT.
GO EAST GO AHEAD OKAY.
IT IF WE CAN HAVE THE NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE.
YEAH.
YOU TOOK MORE THAN SEVEN YEARS
DUE PROCESS THE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
COW A FIFTY MILLION AMERICANS.
GIVEN THAT THE RATE OF GROWTH
WAS EXPECTED TO CONTINUE
CRITICALLY BECAUSE OF INCREASED
IMMIGRATION.
THE BUREAU IS CONCERNED THAT THE
NIGHT EIGHTEEN NINETY COUNT.
MIGHT NOT BE COMPLETED UNTIL
AFTER THE NINETEEN HUNDRED
STARTED.
THE CENSUS BUREAU TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THE COUNTY MACHINE RECENTLY
INVENTED BY HERMAN HOLLERITH AS
CENSUS EMPLOYEE AT THE TIME.
THAT USE SPECIALLY ENCODED PUNCH
CARDS.
EACH REPRESENTING AN INDIVIDUAL
CENSUS DATA.
HOW RICH DEVICE REVOLUTIONIZE
CENSUS TABULATION?
THE EIGHTEEN NINETY COUNT OF
SIXTY THREE MILLION PEOPLE WAS
COMPLETED IN LESS THAN A YEAR.
EVEN THOUGH SENSE IF INCLUDED
THREE TIMES AS MANY QUESTIONS
AND ANOTHER THIRTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE.
THAT IMPROVEMENT IN TIME TO
COUNT WAS IMPRESSIVE.
BUT THE WAY THE INFORMATION WAS
USED ADDS EVEN MORE TO THE STORY.
I COUNTY THIRTEEN MILLION MORE
PEOPLE IN A FRACTION OF THE TIME.
THE CENSUS BUREAU WAS ABLE TO
RELEASE CONSTITUTIONALLY
MANDATED INFORMATION.
THAT BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
REPRESENTATIVES TO CONGRESS TO
INCREASE FROM THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE.
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX.
AMONG THE FASTEST GROWING STATES
AT THAT TIME.
NEBRASKA ADDED THREE
REPRESENTATIVES ABOUT%
PENNSYLVANIA TEXAS
MINNESOTA AND ILLINOIS. EACH
ADDED TO.
IF THE SET FIFTY INCREASE SPEED
OF THE COUNT FROM EIGHTEEN
NINETY HADN'T BEEN POSSIBLE.
THE CITIZENS OF THOSE GROWING
STATES WOULD HAVE BEEN UNDER
REPRESENTED IN CONGRESS.
FOR SEVEN YEARS ARE MARK.
NEXT RIGHT HAND NIGHT JULY OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX.
VICE PRESIDENT ROCKEFELLER VISIT
THE CENSUS BUREAU TO SERVE AS
THE KEYNOTE SPEAKER.
AT A CEREMONY COMMEMORATING THE
TWENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
PERILS IN CIVIC INFLATION. OF
THE UNIVAC ONE THE WORLD'S FIRST
COMMERCIAL ELECTRONIC COMPUTER.
ALSO IN ATTENDANCE REDUCTION
JOHN MOXLEY NJ PRESS PER
ACCURATE.
THE INVENTORS OF THE UNIVAC.
AMONG THE ARTIFACTS ON DISPLAY
WITH THE MEMORY STORAGE UNIT
ROUGHLY THIRTY SIX INCHES LONG.
AND EIGHT INCHES IN DIAMETER.
VICE PRESIDENT ROCKEFELLER
ALWAYS VERY INTERESTED PERSON.
S. MOTLEY INACCURATE.
HOW BIG AN EQUIVALENT STORAGE
DEVICE WOULD BE IN USING CURRENT
TECHNOLOGY?
THE TO THE INVENTORS PAUSE
FIVE A SECOND OR TWO AND THEN
REPLIED.
MR VICE PRESIDENT IT WOULD BE SO
SMALL YOU COULD NOT SEE IT.
AND THIS WAS THE FIRST
COMMERCIAL COMPUTER AND I THINK
IT WAS USED FOR IT AND IT WAS
USED FOR THE CENSUS.
FASCINATED THINK ABOUT THE
EXTENT OF INVOLVEMENT JUST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
SINCE EIGHTEEN NINETY A LOT IS
CHANGING THE WORLD OF DATA
COLLECTION AND PROCESSING.
FOR EXAMPLE THANKS A DEDICATED
WORKERS THAT THE COMPUTER AT THE
STATUES PARA.
PHOTO OPTICAL SCANNING DEVICES
AND UNIVAC ELEVEN TEN. COMPUTER
I WAS ABLE TO DELIVER A
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DETAILED. AND
ACCURATE COUNT OF TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX MILLION FIVE HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIVE PEOPLE TO THE
PRESIDENT. BY JANUARY FIRST
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE.
NINE MONTHS.
AFTER THE BUREAU SENT OUT THE
QUESTIONNAIRES IN APRIL OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY.
THE ADVENT OF THE INTERNET AND
OTHER TECHNOLOGIES THAT LED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SOCIAL MEDIA. AND
MOBILE DEVICES.
WHICH IN TURN HAVE ALTERED THE
WAY PEOPLE INTERACT WITH
BUSINESS GOVERNMENTS AND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
THE SUBSEQUENT CHANGES IN HUMAN
BEHAVIOR DEMAND THAT WE IN FACT
REINVENT THE PROCESS WE USE IN
THE PAST.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE CENSUS
BUREAU HAS ATTEMPTED TO DO FOR
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS.
BUT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT IS THE
MANNER IN WHICH THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION. S. IMPOSED
UNTESTED QUESTIONS AND
PROCEDURES AND HOW THE CENSUS
WILL BE CONDUCTED.
ONCE AGAIN IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
CALIFORNIA LEAD THE WAY TO A
SUCCESSFUL CENSUS.
AND THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE THAT
SPEAK LANGUAGES OTHER THAN
ENGLISH IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET.
IN CALIFORNIA WILL NEED TO TAKE
AN ACTIVE ROLE TO BE SURE EVERY
CALIFORNIA. DISCOUNT DIDN'T
TWENTY SET THIS AND I WOULD ADD
TO THAT.
THE THE THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THE STATEWIDE
DATABASE.
S. CONTINUED BE FULLY FUNDED.
AND STAFF PROPERLY.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE REALLY GREAT
BENEFITS THEY'RE REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION HAVING THAT. ACCESS
TO THAT DATA AVAILABLE.
WELL THAT'S A BRIEF SUMMARY AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO CAN'T CAN'T
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
BROUGH REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE HISTORICAL CONTEXT IN A
COUPLE OF CASES THAT I WASN'T
AWARE OF I WANNA OPEN UP MY
COLLEAGUES. MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THOUGHT THAT SHOW IT WAS THANK
YOU FOR THE HISTORICAL.
RESPECTED I HAVE LIKE SO
HOPEFULLY TWO QUICK QUESTIONS.
BECAUSE I AYE MY DISTRICT FIFTY
NOT DISSIMILAR SOUTH LA HATCHED
SOME OF THE PORCH.
NUMBERS SHOWING AND WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT IF WE GO
BACK AND DO THE SAME THING AGAIN
SO I'M WHAT I'M.
PROGRESS IN THE YOUNG FOLKS
DON'T REMEMBER OF LIKE GOING TO
THE NATION OF ISLAM AND
LISTENING TO HELP OR GOING TO
BOBBY SEALE THE BLACK PANTHERS.%
WAS OUT OF THE BOX.
AND.
AND I THINK WE GOT TO DO SOME
THINGS THAT ARE OUT OF THE BOX
TO GET. PEOPLE MY COMMUNITY
FULLY ARM AND GET INVOLVED AND
AMBIENCE WITH YOU THAT THAT MAY
INVOLVE SOME FOOD SOME MUSIC
THEY MAY INVOLVED IN THINGS THAT
YOU WOULDN'T TRADITIONALLY. DO
SITE CONTA WHEN THEY KNOW HOW.
DID YOU.
AND BACK THEN YOU PROBLEMS
MIDDLE AYE RESISTANCE
TO DO IT ARTS SO I'D WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT THAT AND INTO I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SECURITY. OF THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE IF I I WILL TELL RIGHT
NOW JUST GO TO THE SUPREME COURT.
AND YOU ON ON.
KEEPING THE INFORMATION FROM THE
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES.
IF A BLACK YOURS BECAUSE YOU
YOU WILL NOT GET THE SAME ANSWER
THAT YOU GOT FROM THURGOOD
MARSHALL I GUARANTEE YOU THAT.
AND SO IN MY COMMUNITY THEIR LOT
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE VERY VERY
CONCERNED AND I COULD HAVE A
REALLY DETRIMENTAL IMPACT. IF I
CAN'T.
TELL THEM WITH SOME SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT THOSE RECORDS
WOULDN'T BE USED OR ABUSED.
.
TO TO SEPARATE FAMILIES AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE SO.
THE TO SOMEONE HOW DID YOU BREAK
OUT OF THE BOX AND DO THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN KILL USED THAT'S
ALL I CAN DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY
IN AND TO.
.
DEBT THAT THE SECURITY OF THIS
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
WELL A HE GETTING BACK THE SALE
WAS THEIR REAL INTERESTING AND I
EXERCISE.
.
HE CLEARED HIS ADMINISTRATION
LED BY RICHARD NIXON.
TO ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND SO
WHEN HE CAME WE HAD THIS MEETING.
AND AND THE CONVERSATION WAS NOT
GOING WELL.
AB IT'S CLEAR THAT EVERYBODY WAS
NOT CONFIDENT THAT THEY COULD
TRUST THIS SAID THE CENSUS
BUREAU TO KEEP ALL THE THINGS
THEY WERE SAYING.
SO BOBBY SEE IF THE.
CAN WE TAKE A BREAK AND.
NICE IT CAN WE SEPARATE SO THAT
WE COULD TALK TO OURSELVES.
AND I SAID NO AND A PUBLIC
HEARING. SIZED BY THE GOVERNMENT
SOMEBODY FROM THE GOVERNMENT HAS
TO BE HERE.
THEY SAID CAN WE TAKE A BREAK.
I SAID YEAH SAYS THAT WHAT YOU
TAKE YOUR BREAK OUT THERE WILL
TAKE A BREAK.
BUT FORTY FIVE MINUTES LATER THE
BREAK WAS OVER.
AND THAT IF WE CAME BACK AND HE
SAID WELL WE DECIDED TO GIVE YOU
A CHANCE.
AND THE ONLY REASON WE GIVEN
YOUR CHANCES BECAUSE IF YOU
DON'T DO IT WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY THEY'LL EAT IT ACROSS THE.
AND.
AT IT BUT IT WAS TAKE IT TOOK
SOMEBODY LIKE HIM TO GIVE VINCE
PEOPLE WHO WERE NERVOUS ABOUT IT.
THEY SAY HEY YOU KNOW THIS IS
WORTH TRYING.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T TRY WE'RE
GOING TO GET HURT ANYWAY IT
WHAT'S MORTGAGE ABOUT THE NIXON
GOVERNMENT DAN AT. WELL I COULD
TELL YOU NOBODY IN THAT
GOVERNMENT SAW THE INFORMATION.
WHO HAD AND THAT I COULD TELL
YOU THAT WHAT WHAT YOU HAD A
SUPREME COURT JUDGE THAT GREW
OUT OF QUOTING WHAT YOU SAID
KINDA RULED ANYA FELL OUT AND
THEY DO HAVE A TICKET THEY WOULD
HAVE TO VIOLATE THE LAW AND WHAT
THE JUDGE WAS SAYING AS THE? LAW
STANDS.
AGAIN WHAT I'M SAYING IS THIS
SUPREME COURT MAY SAY SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
EL AND THAT'S WHAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT. AT I WOULD BE A QUIET DAY
I WOULD BE FRANKLY STARTLED IF
THEY DID BECAUSE IT'S SO CLEAR.
THAT YOU CAN A IT'S IT'S REALLY
NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE IN THAT
SENSE.
AND OUT NOW.
WILL THERE BE ATTEMPTS.
I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED BUT I
GOT TO A AND.
PRETTY MUCH AS I HAD TO DO WITH
THE DIRECTOR FOR THE FBI IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. IT WILL BE IN
THOSE ATTEMPTS WILL BE THWARTED.
MY HOPE SO BUT THE EMPLOYEES OF
THE BUREAU.
IF I INVITE WHERE MY GUESS IS
THERE WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT
RESIGNATIONS IF THEY WERE
REQUIRED TO DO THAT BECAUSE IT'S
A VERY BIG EVENT IT'S.
THANK YOU.
.
BARBARA FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AT
A QUESTION SO WE'RE HERE OF
COURSE AS THE.
TELL YOU ALL THAT INFORMATION
HEARING FOR THE.
.
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF SEAT TO
US CENSUS IS RUN BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE ARE CONFLICTS WITH THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
HOW DO YOU SEE WHAT'S THE WORST
THINGS THAT WE AS A STATE CAN DO
TO HELP? BOOST THE CENSUS.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE MAY HAVE
WELL TO CERTAIN GRAY THINK WHERE
COOPERATION TO SOME DEGREE THERE
WE MAY HAVE TO DEAL THERE THEY
MAY NOT COOPERATE GREAT.
SO FEEBLE WE'RE HEARING THAT
INCIDENT WAS IT SIX FOLLOW UP
CAN ONLY DO THREE FOLLOW UP SO.
WE CAN'T ADD MORE FOLLOW UP SO I
DON'T KNOW BUT WHERE THINGS WE
CAN DO IS A STATE.
TO.
IN THE FACE OF A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY RUNNING THE
CENSUS COUNT ITSELF.
TO TRY TO INCREASE THE COUNT.
WHY?
WELL BASICALLY INTERFACING WITH
A SYSTEM THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
WANT TO BE COOPERATIVE WITH OUR
EFFORTS SO IT WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON IRAN THE U. S.
SUCH AS.
WELL. I WOULD SAY THAT THOUGH
YOU. I'M FAMILIAR WITH THE
ISSUES WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND. AS A CITIZEN SHARE YOUR
CONCERN.
THE.
THE EMPLOYEES OF THE BUREAU ONE
ACCOUNT EVERYONE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
AND THEY WILL DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN WITHIN THE RULES THAT ARE
PLACED UPON THEM.
TO DO THAT AND ONE OF THE RULES
SAYS THEY SHALL NOT VIOLATE
TITLE THIRTEEN OF THE U. S. CODE.
SO I WOULD SAY THAT WHAT YOU
HAVE STARTED HERE IN THE STATE
WHICH IS AN OUTREACH PROGRAM.
GOES WELL BEYOND WHAT THE CENSUS
BUREAU COULD AFFORD TO DO.
AND IT'S PROBABLY. CONSIDERED
MARK SEPT ABOVE BY THE CITIZENS
OF THE STATE. ISSUE HAVING
CALIFORNIANS ASCHAM TO
PARTICIPATE BECAUSE IT'S IN THE
INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIANS.
I AND IT'S GONNA BE DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
WHEN YOUR IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IT'S GOING TO BE IN THE TIGHTLY
DIFFERENT SET OF. ISSUES THEN
YOU RENDON'S THEN SOUTH PART OF
LOS ANGELES
HER UP IN HAVE IN THE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE ARE THE BAY
AREA.
SO.
HAVING THE.
THE OUTREACH PROGRAM THAT YOU
STARTED.
FUNDED PROPERLY.
AND THEN BUT THE BACKGROUND OF
FINDING THE RIGHT PEOPLE FINING
THE LANI SHABAZZ'S OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES.
IN MY MIND WHO IS PROBABLY THE
MOST MEANINGFUL THING YOU CAN DO.
AND THAT THIS WILL NOT BE
INEXPENSIVE THAT I IT WILL BE
VERY EXPENSIVE.
TO DO THAT AND THAT THE OTHER
THING I WOULD DE SUGGESTS IS THE.
MAKING SURE THAT THAT DATABASE
HAS SET UP READY TO GO BECAUSE
ACCESS THING THAT DID THIS SENSE
THIS IS GOING TO BE REALLY
INTERESTING. GIVEN ALL THE
THINGS ARE GOING ON BETWEEN IT
AND ITS AVAILABILITY.
AND THAT'S WHY HAVING ACCESS
THAT INFORMATION AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S GOOD AND
WHAT'S MAYBE NOT GOOD ABOUT IT
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT.
MISTER JOHN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUT OFFICE ALL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AYE YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY IN SOCIAL MEDIA. ARE
IN THIS UPCOMING OUR SENSES AND
I WAS JUST WONDERING WHAT
MEASURES.
WOULD.
POTENTIALLY BE IMPLEMENTED TO
SAFEGUARD OUR OTHER DE
INFORMATION OVER THE THE DATA
THAT WE CAN IT BE COLLECTING. A
FROM THESE PEOPLE IN TERMS OF UP
A CYBERSECURITY IS CONCERNED I
MEAN HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT DOG
DE DATABASE THAT YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER. WOULD NOT BE HACKED
INTO OR OR A TAMPER WITH. A THIS
IS BECAUSE SOME WHAT SIMILAR TO
THE SECURITY ISSUE A QUESTION
THAT WAS RAISED EARLIER BUT THIS
IS MORE IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNOLOGY PIECE.
IN LIGHT OF THE YEAR.
DE ADVANCE IN COMBATING
KNOWLEDGE IN COMPUTERS.
I I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT IT IS
WILL BE AVAILABLE BECAUSE.
PROBABLY AYE MY UNDERSTATEMENT
THIS BIKE BUT I DO KNOW THAT THE
CENSUS BUREAU HAVE THAT LISTED
AS ONE OF THEIR BIGGEST CONCERNS.
BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENED BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE PROCEDURES ARE TECHNOLOGIES
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THANKS.
AND ALSO ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER BROUGH.
WHAT IS ONE OF THE THINGS I'M AT?
I THINK WHAT WHAT YOU SAID IT
WAS REINFORCED BY MISTER JONES
SAWYER ABOUT THAT THE SANCTITY
OF THAT INFORMATION THE SECURITY
OF OF THE DATA THAT'S COLLECTED
IN THE FACT THAT IT CANNOT BE
USED FOR ANY OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
PURPOSE. IT WOULD WE HAVE IT A
DYE JOB WE WE FIRST HAVE TO
COMMIT OURSELVES OF THAT FACT.
THEN WE HAVE TO CONVINCE THE
STAKEHOLDERS OF THAT FACT AND
EMPOWER THEM TO GOING CAN IT'S
THEIR COMMUNITIES. OF THAT FACT
AND IT'S GONNA BE A REALLY YOU
KNOW THAT IMPORTANT AND
CHALLENGING.
EFFORT BECAUSE THERE ISN'T A
LOT OF TRUST.
RIGHT NOW AND AND RIGHTFULLY SO
AND AND SO.
THE OF THESE TO THOSE TWO
HISTORICAL EXAMPLES OF TIMES THE
GOVERNMENT ON IT ENTITIES HAVE
TRIED TO TO USE THAT INFO AT
HAVE BEEN STOPPED.
IS INCREDIBLY HELPFUL DOCTORS
OUT I MEAN.
DOCTOR PAIN IN I WERE WERE IN A
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY WITH A
GROUP OF FOUNDATIONS AND THIS
ISSUE CAME UP AND.
YOU KNOW WE DISCUSSED THE NEED
TO REALLY COME UP WITH MATERIAL
THAT THAT.
GIVES PEOPLE THAT CONFIDENCE.
AND HAVING THOSE TWO HISTORICAL
EXAMPLES WILL DEFINITELY HELP
WITH THAT BECAUSE.
NOT YOU KNOW IF WE CAN CONVINCE
PEOPLE THAT THEN THEN WE HAVEN'T
DONE OUR JOB AND I THINK YOU
WOULD FIND.
OTHER EXAMPLES THAT MARK CURRENT
YEAH WELL IF I HAD A BET NAY AND
BEGIN THE SET UP I'M SURE WILL
BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THOSE.
BUT THE REAL KEY AND.
IT'S NOT THE LEGISLATURE TALKING
TO THE CITIZENSHIP.
IT'S A LIVE ISSUE PASSES TALKING
THING YEAH YEAH THAT'LL HAVE
EASILY. THIS TRUSTED MESSENGERS
YOU BETTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MS AND BROUGHT REALLY APPRECIATE
IT.
JONES WAS BECAUSE YOU DON'T NEED
TO.
HEY SO.
OUR NEXT PANEL IS THAT IT IS
THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT.
GROUP WE HAVE A DANIEL TOURISTS
THAT DIRECTIVE AND WE HAVE
IMMIGRANT INTEGRATION AT THE
OFFICE THE GOVERNOR AND CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE AND.
THE THIS AYE TO TIDY IS ALSO
DIRECTOR OF THE CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. AND.
ASK YOU CAN THAT FIND MAXIMO
FIVE MINUTES APIECE AND THEN
THAT WAY WE WILL HAVE TYPER Q.
IN A AS WELL SO THANKS SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL.
THINK YOU GOOD MORNING GERMAN
PANGERAN BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF.
MY NAME IS DAN TAURUS. AND THE
DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRANT AGGRESSION
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
ALPHASERVER IS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMPLETE CAO
COMMITTEE. AND I'LL BE SPEAKING
TODAY ABOUT THE WORK OF THE
CONFERENCE COMPLETE CAO
COMMITTEE AND THE CENSUS TWENTY
TWENTY CAMPAIGN. AND MY
COLLEAGUE DE DESK TIDY WILL BE
PRESENTING ON THE FEDERAL CENSUS
OPERATION AND CALIFORNIA'S PLAN
FOR SUCH A SWEET TWENTY.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING US TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE OF THE WORK I HAD THE
GOVERNOR IS VERY COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
FAIR COMPETE COUNTS AS A TWENTY
TWENTY.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE WORK OF
GETTING A COMPLETE CAO CAN ONLY
BE DONE TO CREATE PARTNERSHIPS
INCLUDING A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TEAR
STAFF AYE WHO'D BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH US IN AND
DEVELOPING OUR STRATEGY. AND I
AM JOINING US IN THE FIELD
TALKING TO STAKEHOLDERS ON WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A COMPLETE CAO.
THE MISSION OF OUR CAMPAIGN IS
TO ENSURE THAT CONFERENCE GET
THEIR FAIR SHARE OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES AND CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATION. BY ENCOURAGING
THE FULL PARTICIPATION OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS INSTANCES TWENTY
TWENTY.
OUR GOALS ENSURE THAT EVERYONE
IS COUNTY ONCE
ONLY ONCE AND IN THE RIGHT PLACE.
AND ONE OF THAT ONE OF THE MAIN
STRATEGIES AS AS DOCTOR AS
DIRECTOR BROUGH I MENTIONED IS
IS THE DEVELOPMENT OF A OF A
STATEWIDE COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE. AND THAT AND THIS
CASE WILL SERVE AS AN ADVISORY
BODY TO THE OVERALL A STATE
CAMPAIGN.
AND THE COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEE
THAT WILL DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS ON STRATEGIES TO
EDUCATE MOTIVATE. AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS PARTICIPATE IN THE
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY.
EFFORT THE GOVERNOR I APPOINTED
TWENTY FIVE MEMBERS TO THE CAN A
FAKE COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEE. AND.
AND ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THE
ADVICE A DOCTOR BRAVA AND THEIR
TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
REPRESENTATIVE OF HARD TO COUNT
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. TRUSTED MESSENGERS
LEADERS ARE YOU. FOLKS THAT WILL
HELP VALIDATE OUR OUR EFFORTS TO
AND. AND MESSAGE AROUND WHY IT'S
IN THE INTEREST OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS.
AND BASICALLY REPRESENTATIVES
FROM BUSINESS LABOR GOVERNMENT
EDUCATION FAITH BASED
INSTITUTIONS MEDIA PHILANTHROPIC
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. THE
SENATE PROTANDIM AND SPEAKER OF
EACH APPOINTED A MEMBER TO THE
COMMITTEE.
AND THEY HAVE THEY WILL
COLLABORATE WITH OUR STATE
OFFICE IN THE AND THE US CENSUS
BUREAU AND OFFER THEIR OWN
EXPERTISE ON HOW TO DEVELOP.
A COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
REACH HARD ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES
AND THEY'LL THAN IF I AFFECTED
MATH METHODS ABOUT WHICH OF A OF
A LONG CAREERS IN IN IN DOING
OUTREACH ON DIFFICULT ISSUES.
AND THEY WILL ASSIST US WITH
DEVELOPING LOCAL RELATIONSHIPS
AND MBAS ON WITH VOCAL COMPLETE
CAO COMMITTEES. AND MOBILIZE
THEIR GRASSROOTS AND NETWORKS TO
TO HELP EFFECTIVE EFFORT.
AND THEY ALSO HAVE A WEALTH OF
HAVE HAD CONNECTIONS TO OUTSIDE
EXPERTS THAT THEY MAY WILL BRING
INTO THIS CONVERSATION HELP WITH.
DIED DIG MORE DEEPLY INTO IT WE
NEED TO DO. IN THE PAST THE
FLICK COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEES
HAVE.
HAD THE SAME PURPOSE AND AND
AND DEVELOPING ADVICE TO THE
STATE EFFORT AND THAT THE
CONFIGURATIONS OF THE COMMITTEES
HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT. AND TWO
THOUSAND WE HAD EIGHTEEN MEMBER
COMMITTEE.
ALSO VERY REPRESENTATIVE APART
ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES IN TWENTY
TEN AND WE HAD A FIFTY TWO
MEMBER COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEE
ARMED THAT SERVE MORE AS A
SPEAKERS BUREAU.
AND SO THIS TIME AROUND WE WILL
WE WANT TO GET BACK TO YOU A
MISSION OF FOCUSING ON THE HARD
TO COUNT COMMUNITIES AND GETTING.
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THOSE
COMMUNITIES AT THE TABLE FOR THE
CAN HELP ON STRUCTURE IN AND
ADVISE US ON HOW TO. HOW TO
REACH THOSE COMMUNITIES WE'VE
HAD ONE MEETING ALREADY?
AND THAT CAN BECOME COMMITTEE
HAS DECIDED TO PRIOR. TO TAKE ON
FOR INITIAL ISSUES OF CONCERN
AND HAVE DEVELOPED WORKING GROUP
THAT TO TAKE ON THOSE CHALLENGES.
AND THE FOR INCLUDE HOUSING
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
STRATEGY TO TODAY. TO LOCATE
PEOPLE AND THEY KNOW WHERE TO
COUNT PEOPLE SO GETTING ALL THE
DIFFERENT INPUTS DATA I. FINING
THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT SERVE
HOMELESS POPULATIONS MITCHELL
BEAR INFORMING US AND THE
FEDERAL BUREAU ON WHERE TO
LOCATE PEOPLE. A FARM WORKER
HOUSING ALL THAT REPORTERS AND
AND AND A LOT OF NEW I YOU KNOW
DEVELOPMENT SAID THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ON THE RADAR BEFORE.
SECOND GROUP WILL BE WORKING ON
CONTENT OF THE OFFENSIVE
QUESTIONER INCLUDING THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION. I WHICH WE
KNOW IS WHICH WOULD BE VERY
CHALLENGING FOR CALIFORNIA GIVEN
THAT. THAT WE HAVE.
YOU TEN MILLION OVER TEN PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE FOREIGN BORN
BUT TWO POINT FIVE MILLION THAT
ARE UNDOCUMENTED. MANY
HOUSEHOLDS WITH MIXED STATUS
MEMBERS AND THAT ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT COMPLETING THE
QUESTIONNAIRE SO THE WORKING
GROUP'S FORMING TO HELP US THINK
ABOUT HOW TO. ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION THE THIRD GROUP IS TO
IS FORMING ON TRUSTING
CONFIDENTIALITY TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE REACH. UP ALL ISSUE THE
OF EARNED SECURITY CLEAN
CYBERSECURITY SHARING OF DATA
AND AND MESSAGING AROUND TITLE
THIRTEEN.
AND A FOURTH GROUP THAT'LL
FOCUS ON ACCESS ISSUE THAT THAT
WHICH INCLUDE LANGUAGE ACCESS
REACHING LANGUAGE ISOLATED
COMMUNITIES. AND ARE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES MAKE SURE OUR
MATERIALS AND IN THE FEDERAL
MATERIALS ARE ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
IN CONTRAST PRIOR EFFORTS WE ARE
THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN FORMED TO
YEARS IN ADVANCE OF THE CENSUS%
SO. AND THAT GIVES US MORE TIME
THE BEFORE TO LEVERAGE THEIR
EXPERTISE AND NETWORKS KING AND
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING. AND
AFTER OUR FIRST MEETING I CAN
TELL YOU THE COMMITTEE IS VERY.
ENGAGE AND IS EMBRACING THE
CHALLENGES THAT.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA PASSES
OVER TO TEACH OF KENTUCKY DS
WITH THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CENSUS TWO THOUSAND CAMPAIGN FOR
CALIFORNIA. AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE TWENTY TEN CAMPAIGN AND
SHE'LL BE AGAIN TALKING ABOUT
THE FEDERAL OPERATION AND
CALIFORNIA'S PLAN.
THANK YOU DAN WHAT I WANTED TO
ACTUALLY THINK OWN DIRECTOR
BROUGH BECAUSE OF THAT ORIGINAL.
RACE ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT
THEY SET UP AT THE CENSUS BUREAU
WHEN HE WAS THERE HAS EVOLVED TO
THE NATIONAL VICE OUR COMMITTEE
ON RACE ETHNICITIES AND OTHER
POPULATIONS. AND I'VE BEEN
SERVING ON THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE AND I BEEN THE
CHAIR SINCE PROM TO THAT THE
FIFTEEN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF SO I KNOW THAT WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANYONE FROM.
THE CENSUS BUREAU CURRENTLY SO
SLIDES AND ALL TALK REALLY FAST
BECAUSE I KNOW I HAVE. A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME ONE AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS TO THAT IT IS A
FEDERAL OPERATION IT'S THE MOST
COMPLEX FOR OPERATION IMPACTS OF
COURSE ARE APPORTIONMENT
REDISTRICTING. JUST REACHED OF
DOLLARS AS MENTIONED IT'S
INCLUSIVE EVENT AND IT'S REALLY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AT ITS FINEST
AND FOR ME I COME BACK. WAS MY
THIRD DECENNIAL BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IT'S A FOUNDATION TOWARD
DEMOCRACY
SO REALLY QUICKLY I'D REALLY
LIKE THE SLIDE THAT.
THE.
JAMIE CHRISTY FROM THE US
CENSUS PARA HEDGE SET UP SHARED
WITH OUR COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE AGAIN IT'S REALLY POOR
MAJOR OPERATIONS BROKE IT YOU
KNOW IT'S A VERY COMPLEX
OPERATION BUT THEY PUT IT INTO
THESE BUCK.
WHICH IS THEY GOT ESTABLISH
WHERE ACCOUNT IT'S ADDRESS BASED
SADDAM BY EMAIL OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT ALTHOUGH THE RESPONSES CAN
BE DONE ONLINE. SO RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE CURRENTLY UNDERGOING THE
LOCAL UPDATE OF SINCE ADDRESSES
WHICH IS CALLED LUKA. WHICH THE
GOVERNOR PUT IT ASIDE AND YOU
GET PASSED A SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON MANY OF YOUR LOCAL
AREAS ARE ACTUALLY DOING THAT
THAT'S SUPER IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT'S THE INVITATION LIST.
IF YOU GET THAT WRONG YOU'RE NOT
GONNA GET A FOR.
SO THEN THE SENTENCES PEROT
MOTIVATES PEOPLE RESPOND THAT'S
WHERE WE CAN HELP WE CAN HELP AT
THE STATE LEVEL ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL. ALONG THESE.
THESE THE IT'S AREAS SO COURSE
ESTABLISHING RECOUNT BUT THE
LOCALS WE CAN HELP THE CENSUS
BUREAU GET THE RIGHT LIST.
MOTIVATING PEOPLE TO RESPOND AS
DIRECTOR BROUGH SAID IT'S REALLY.
IT'S LOCALLY DONE IN TERMS OF
TO BE MOST EFFECTIVE KNOW ALL OF
US COULD SIT HERE AND HELP ME TO
BE COUNTED BUT IT REALLY COUNTS
WHEN ITS LOCAL TRUSTED
MESSENGERS.
THEN THE CENSUS BUREAU ITSELF
COUNTS THE POPULATION THEY ARE
ENUMERATORS THEY ARE PAID BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT SO
WE HAVE SOME. PARAMETERS AROUND
THAT OF WHERE WE CAN HELP BUT WE
CAN CERTAINLY PROVIDE THE
SURROUND SOUND TO GET PEOPLE TO
RESPOND AND THEN THE CENSUS
BUREAU RELEASES THE CENSUS
RESULTS ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY. THE ACCOUNT
GOES TO THE PRESIDENT AND THEN
THOSE APARTMENT DATA COMES OUT
AND THEN THAT'S WHERE WE FIGURE
OUT IF WE ARE GAIN STATUS A
STEADY OR LOST A SEAT. AND THEN
ON APRIL FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS WHEN THE DAY COMES BACK
TO THE STATES AND CURRENT AND
HER GROUP AND VINCE AND HIS
GROUP START TO LOOK AT IT FOR A
REDISTRICTING.
ALRIGHT BECAUSE OF ALL SEE THIS.
AGO HAD SKIPPED THROUGH THAT I
WANTED TO PROVIDE THIS BECAUSE
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION WE'VE
BEEN GOING OUT. COME ACROSS THE
STATE
RECENTLY DOING ARE CONVENING
STATE ANTI TRUST THE MESSENGERS
AND THERE IS SOME CONFUSION
ABOUT HOW IS THIS THING TO BE
DONE ONLINE. I CAN TALK FURTHER
ABOUT BUT REALLY IT'S A MAILING
THEY GET A LETTER THAT SAYS GO
ONLINE AND DO YOU KNOW TO EIGHT
DAYS LATER IF YOU DON'T RESPOND
YOU CAN OTHER LETTER. SO YOU
NEVER REALLY GET A FORM UNTIL
REALLY. A MONTH AFTER YOU GET
THAT FIRST LETTER IF YOU DON'T
RESPOND YOU GET A LETTER PLUS A
QUESTION HERE AND THEN IF YOU
DON'T RESPOND TO THAT AND OTHER
DAYS WILL GET ANOTHER POSTCARD
SAYING IT'S NOT TOO LATE. AND
THEN ALMOST A MONTH AFTER YOU
GET THEIR SIX WEEKS AFTER YOU
GET THAT CONTACT.
THAT'S WHEN YOU START TO BE PUT
ON THE LIST FOR NON RESPONSE
FOLLOW UP
SO I JUST WANTED THEY SORT OF
CLARIFY THAT SO THAT'S ALL WE
CAN TALK ABOUT TERMS OF FEDERAL
OPERATIONS.
YOU BECAUSE I KNOW WANT TO HEAR
REALLY ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT TO SOME OF THE BASIC STUFF.
WAS OUT THERE.
SO BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW THE.
WE'VE DONE THIS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND TEN WE'VE HAD.
VARYING DEGREES OF SUCCESS TWO
THOUSAND WAS INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL WE'VE USED A LOT OF
THE LESSONS LEARNED FROM TWO
THOUSAND CURRENTLY THE STATEWIDE
RITA READINESS A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT I JUST WANT TO SAY
CHAIRMAN BERMAN CHARM PAN. THESE
TO US STAFFERS ON EITHER SIDE OF
YOU HAVE BEEN JUST CRITICAL IN
GETTING THE RIGHT PEOPLE AT
THESE CAN BE THINGS AS WELL AS
OURS ARE A SLEW OF OTHER PEOPLE
BEHIND THEM. THAT HAVE AS WELL
WOULDN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO IT
WITHOUT THEM WE'VE DONE SEVEN OF
THE OVER TWENTY FIVE THAT WE'RE
GONNA DO WANNA DO FOUR
ADDITIONAL TRIBAL CONSULTATIONS
AS WELL. BECAUSE AS DIRECTOR
BROUGH SAID YOU HAVE TO GO OUT.
YEAH WE WERE UP IN UKIAH DOWN
INCURRING WERE HEADING TO
RIVERSIDE TOMORROW PALM DESERT
IN IN EVERY PLACE THAT WE BEEN
IT'S BEEN TOTALLY DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT WHAT THEIR FEARS ARE. HOW
THEY THINK THEY CAN GET THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO RESPOND
SO IT'S BEEN SUPER IMPORTANT?
AS WE DIDN'T TWO THOUSAND TWO
THOUSAND TEN A STATE AGENCY
WORKING GROUP THAT'S AGAIN
THAT'S THE LOW HANGING FRUIT
THAT'S LEVERAGING YOU KNOW EDIE
DIS GOT OFFICES THEY SENT UP PAY
STUBS THEY CAN SEND OUT. DMV'S
GOT KIOSKS THEY CONSENT AS MUCH
COMMUNICATIONS THEY WANT
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE OTHER.
BUCKETS OF AREAS THAT WE PLAN
TO DO WORK AND I CAN ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS ON THAT. I WANT TO
POINT OUT SOME OF THE. THE
ISSUES THOUGH IT IS THE FIRST
DIGITAL CENSUS.
AND YOU KNOW THE CENSUS BUREAU
ATTIRE WE'RE DOING IT BECAUSE I
WANNA SAY PAPER IT'S GONNA BE
EASIER FOR OUR BACK OFFICES. BUT
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE A REAL
PAIN HONESTLY WE'VE HEARD THE
OPEN UKIAH THEY DON'T HAVE
BROADBAND IN THOSE AREAS WERE
HURT WILL HURT FROM RURAL AREAS.
SO SIGNIFICANT EVEN HERE IN YOLO
COUNTY REYES.
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES GRAY EVEN
IN IN URBAN AREAS IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CALIFORNIA BODMIN COUNCIL ON
HOW WE MAPPED OUT BROADBAND WE
HAVE SIGNIFICANT AREAS THAT
DON'T HAVE REALLY YOU KNOW
DEPENDABLE. A ONLINE ACCESS
WE TALK ABOUT THE LACK OF
FEDERAL FUNDING AND THE
DIVERSITY BUT I DID WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENTS
OR TALK A LITTLE BIT CHALLENGES
WHICH WE CAN SPEND MORE TIME ON.
THE LET'S TALK ABOUT AN
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO HUGE
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH IS THE
GOVERNOR GEENA COMMITTED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR AND
AGAIN THE PROPOSED FORTY POINT
THREE MILLION. THIS TIME AROUND
WHICH WERE GOING THROUGH
HEARINGS THAT'S AN UNPRECEDENTED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
NO ONE ACROSS THE STATE I'VE
KNOWN ACROSS THE NATION HAS EVER
COMMITTED THAT WE ARE HEAD OF
THE ENTIRE NATION IN DOING THIS.
ARM AND SO I THINK WE HAVE SOME
HUGE OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
ENGAGE FOUNDATIONS AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS RITUAL HERE FROM A
LATER ON TODAY.
ARE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
HERE'S THE LINE ITEMS DOES HAVE
THAT WE HAVE OUR APPROACH MODUS
CRUISES THAT WHEN YOU GUYS CAN.
AND THEN BASICALLY I DID WANT TO
TOUCH ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PERFORMANCE MEASURES BECAUSE I
KNOW WHEN YOU'RE DOING ANY KIND
OF. LARGE YOU KNOW STATE
BUDGETING PEOPLE ARE NOT REALLY
AWARE THAT THEY WANT TO DO THAT
SO I JUST WANT TO TAKE A QUICK
MOMENT ALSO THAT'S OKAY TO TALK
ABOUT THE SLIDE. IN TERMS OF
PERFORMANCE MEASURES
SO ANY OF THE THE DOLLARS THAT
ARE STATE OURS THAT ARE USED
WILL COURSE FOLLOW STRICT
CONTRACT MONITORING PAYMENTS
WILL BE LINKED TO SALAS FOR
TRACTOR PERFORMANCE.
PERFORMANCE CRITERIA EVALUATION
WILL BE DEVELOPED WOULD HAVE
READ A REGULAR REPORTING.
WELL HAVE ONSITE MONITORING
SOMETIMES ANNOUNCE SOMETIMES
ANNOUNCED AND OF COURSE THE
FOLLOW DE JESS'S GENERAL TERMS
AND CONDITIONS OF THESE ARE
TAKEN STRAIGHT FROM THE STATE
ACCOUNTABILITY STE.
AND I CAN TALK ABOUT THE RESULT
BEINGS BUT OF COURSE YOUR STAFF
HAS BEEN THERE BUT IT REALLY
GOES TO WHAT DIRECTOR BROUGH
THIS TALK ABOUT ABOUT BUILDING
THAT GROUND GAME. THOSE TRUSTED
PARTNERS ON THE GROUND IN MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S A LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS.
THERE'S JUST A QUICK YOU GUYS
HAVE THAT HANDOUT WERE REALLY
BUSY IN THE NEXT TWELVE WEEKS.
AND HERE THIS IS HOW THEY FEEL
IT FIT IN.
AND THERE'S A SOME CRITICS A
SUSPECT.
BUT I WILL STOP RIGHT THERE AND
ANSWER QUESTIONS PUBLIC TO TALK
REALLY FAST. OKAY WHAT WELL
THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT.
.
IN ASKING YOU TRY TO.
COVER ALL THIS BOTH OF EACH IN
FIVE MINUTES I THINK IS VERY
SHORT ABOUT TIME BUT.
.
I. HOPE PEOPLE TAKE TIME TO LOOK
AT THAT SLIDES IN MORE DETAIL.
.
BEFORE I TAKE QUESTIONS FROM OUR
MEMBERS I DID JUST HAVE ONE
BECAUSE WE TALK ABOUT BUDGET.
OUR RESPECTIVE BUDGET COMMITTEES
ARE MEETING SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
CERTAINLY.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS A PRIORITY ON THE
CENSUS SO WE TALKED IN THE
BEGINNING ABOUT ACTUALLY HOW
MUCH MORE MONEY COMES IN FROM
THE SENSES.
AS WELL.
.
LAYS THROUGHOUT THIS QUESTION.
DEL FOR COVER CALIFORNIA.
WHEN WE HAD TO THE ACA.
SPENT ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION TO
GET OUT THERE TO GET PEOPLE TO
KNOW THE GET PEOPLE SIGNED UP
FOR HEALTH INSURANCE.
YEAH I KNOW SOME OF THAT BE
HEARING FROM SOME THE COUNTIES
AND CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT.
THEY HAVE A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE
IN TRYING TO HELP IDENTIFY
PEOPLE AS WELL AS THE PERSUASION
PART.
SOMETIMES PEOPLE DOING IT KIND
OF PART TIME AS PART OF YOU KNOW
THAT IN ADDITION TO THEIR
CURRENT JOBS AND SO FORTH THAT.
.
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DEAL WITH MADE THESE
BARRIERS.
WELL YOU KNOW I I KNOW YOU SAID
AND PRECEDENT BY UNDERSTAND THAT
THE AMOUNT WAS ACTUALLY BECAUSE
THAT WAS HOW MUCH WE SPEND
PREVIEW IN THE PREVIOUS SEPSIS
BEFORE.
WHY? WHY SHOULDN'T WE ACTUALLY
BE INVESTING A LOT MORE AND AND
AND THE CENSUS COUNT?
YOU HAVE COVERED CALIFORNIA
NEEDS A OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
TO DO THAT.
AND SO AND WE KNOW WE KNOW WE'RE
STILL UNDER COUNTING.
SHOULDN'T THE STATE BE PUTTING
MORE MONEY INTO IT ACTUALLY
RETURN IS A VERY GOOD ONE.
SO.
SO I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
QUESTION.
BECAUSE WE'RE RIGHT NOW TALKING
ABOUT OUR BUDGET AND I THINK YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY THE SENATE AND I
KNOW THE ASSEMBLY OF BOTH
INTERESTED IN BEING SURE WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO TRULY.
GET A COMPLETE COUNT AND I OF
THE GOVERNOR DOES AS WELL BUT WE
THINK.
GIVEN THE SCALE OF THIS SO WE
WE SHOULD BE.
ALLOCATING MORE RESOURCES AND
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION.
I'LL START I I THINK THAT I'M.
THE PLANET IT'S OVER FIFTY
COLLEGE WITH LAST YEAR'S PERHAPS
TEN MILLION IT'S FIFTY MILLION
SUCH TWICE
THE AMOUNT THAT WAS. AND
EXPANDED IN THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
YEAR WHICH TWO THOUSAND AND THE
GROWING AT TWENTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION PART ONE FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION. INVESTED IN
TWO THOUSAND I THINK YOU KNOW I
AM WHAT I KNOW IT W. ONGOING
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE FINAL NUMBER
WHATEVER YOU KNOW THE INTO
LEGISLATION GOVERNOR LAND I
THINK THE KEY PRINCIPLES HERE
WILL BE TO. MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THESE THE STRATEGIES THAT WE'VE
LAID OUT IN TERMS OF HAVING
TRUST THE MESSENGERS THAT GET
FUNDED THAT WE HAVE. PAID MEDIA
STRATEGY THAT WE HAVE A STRATEGY
THAT IN CORPORATE LOCAL SCHOOLS
AND THEY PLAY IMPORTANT ROLE IN
EDUCATING STUDENTS ABOUT THE
CENSUS WITH AND EDUCATE THEIR
PARENTS AND COMMUNITIES. AND THE
LOCAL COMPLETE COUNT COMMITTEES
ALSO ARE INCENTIVIZE TO
PARTICIPATE WE MEDIA AND OUR
PROPOSAL UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS
A MULTI PRONGED STRATEGY WE HAVE
TO GET A LOT OF FOLKS ON. TO GET
ON THE SAME PAGE AS OTHERS FOLKS
HAVE SAID TODAY TO EDUCATE AND
THE STATE ABOUT THE PROCESS AND
TO MOTIVATE AND THEN GET FOLKS
TO PARTICIPATE SO THAT'S. TO
HAVE YOU LEFT FOR CALIFORNIA WE
MEET THE DEFINITION THAT.
AND IT IN THE IN THE MISSIONS
THAT REALLY.
THREE YEAR.
OPERATION AND.
SO I THINK THAT'S THAT'S.
I THINK THE INTERESTS ARE ONLINE
AND THESE KEY STRATEGIES I THINK
HAVE TO REMAIN IN PLAY. AND TO
OUR WEEKLY LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHERE THINGS WHEN I KNOW
THERE ARE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
IDEAS RIGHT NOW AND.
THAT HE PROPOSED ABOUT WHICH
STRATEGIES TO GET MORE FUNDING
VERSUS OTHERS BUT I THINK THE
COMBINATION CAN BE VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND I'LL POINT OUT THAT.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE DID THAT
THE STATE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH MONEY
AT ALL BUT.
MANY OF FOUNDATIONS THAT YOU
CAN SPEAK TO TODAY PUT UP FROM
THEIR OWN COFFERS ALMOST NINE
TEN MILLION OF THEIR OWN. AND SO.
IN THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE BEEN
HAVING OVER THE LAST YEAR WITH
ENGAGED
FOUNDATIONS THAT PRETTY STUNNED
I KIND OF CHALLENGE THEM TO GO
AHEAD AND MATCH. A WHATEVER WE
DO THE STATE'S SO.
YOUR TO BE SPENT TO THE MOBILE
AT WORK AND I APPRECIATE IT AND
I THINK PHILANTHROPY HAS BEEN
STEPPING UP.
BUT I THINK THE STATE CAN ALSO.
DO MORE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE PLAN
BRASSO THINK THAT ESPECIALLY
WILL TRY TO REACH OUT TO MORE
THE YOU KNOW TRUSTED MESSENGERS.
I'M NOT ALL AMERICA HAVE DONE
AUDITS EVERY YEAR AND ALL THE
SUDDEN.
SO I APPRECIATE CON ABILITY
PIECE BUT I ALSO WONDER. TO WHAT
DEGREE.
THAT ALSO MAKES IT HARDER FOR
US TO ENGAGE SOME OF THAT
TRUSTED MANAGED MESSENGERS AND.
MORE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND AND MORE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. AND SO HOW
WE PARTNER WITH OUR
PHILANTHROPIC AND OTHER.
NONPROFIT CPOS AND SO FORTH
THAT TO TO REALLY REACH OUT YOU
KNOW THEY'RE NOT THE ONES WHO
ARE WATCHING MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
THERE MAY NOT BE THE ONES WHO
ARE ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT YOU KNOW WE GOT IT MANY
TAKE SOME. SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE TO GET THEM
AND ALSO BE SURE WE PROVIDE
SUPPORT THAT ARE YOU KNOW. AT
OUR LOCAL LEVELS WELL UMPIRE
CITY AND COUNTY PARTNERS AS WELL
BE SURE THAT THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO IT BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A LOT MORE TO LOCAL
CONNECTION.
SO IT'S ONE BE SURE WE ARE YOU
KNOW POSITIONING OURSELVES FOR
THAT.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THERE ARE SOME NEVER GONNA JONES
SAWYER.
SO SO I ALSO.
DON'T LIKE REINVENT WILL TAUGHT
HOUSE WANNA KNOW WHAT DIDN'T
WORK BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THAT
SEEMS LIKE A AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT
WORKED.
BUT HE DID WORK IN MY.
COMMUNITY BEFORE SO BESIDES ME
BLAMING MY PREDECESSOR I NEED TO
KNOW SPECIFICALLY. HOME.
WHAT I CAN DO DIFFERENTLY
TO GET MY NUMBERS UP THE MORE
IMPORTANT?
WHAT WE DIDN'T DO OR?
WHAT DO WE DO SO A STRATEGY WE
THOUGHT WAS GOING TO WORK AN
ABSOLUTELY FAILED CAN YOU
PINPOINT?
WITH SOME SPECIFICITY TO EACH OF
OUR ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS WHAT
WORKED SOME.
THIS WORKED GREAT FOR AND THERE
DAY OFF THE CHARTS AS FAR AS OF
SUCCESS.
BUT THERE SOME THAT IT DIDN'T
WORK FOR TO YOU YOU CAN'T GIVE.
EVERY DISTRICT IT KIND OF.
BOILERPLATE THIS IS WHAT WILL
WORK IN EVERY DISTRICT SO WHICH
ARE RUN BY REPORT FROM TWO
THOUSAND BUT I WAS JUST LOOKING
AT YESTERDAY AND.
ACTUALLY THE AREAS THAT WE IN
TWO THOUSAND WE ONLY INVESTED
AREAS THAT WERE HARD TO COUNT
THAT HAD A HIGH INTO ACCOUNT.
AND IN THE CITY OF COMPTON IT
HAD THE HIGHEST INCREASE
A RETURN RATE IT WAS SIXTEEN
PERCENT SO WAS A RICH IT WENT UP
TO SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT SO
WHAT'S MINUS SIXTEEN. AND THEN
SANTA ANA ALSO HAD A FOURTEEN
PERCENT INCREASE AND AMANTE HOW
THE FOURTEEN PERCENT INCREASE I
JUST REMEMBER THOSE THREE
BECAUSE I WROTE THEM DOWN. FOR
YESTERDAY'S HEARING AND THAT'S
WHERE WE ACTUALLY INVESTED ON
THE GROUND WE PUT A YOU KNOW
QUESTION YOUR ASSISTANCE IN
THERE AND THEN THE DEPARTMENT
FINE IT'S ACTUALLY CAME BACK TO
THE DEMOGRAPHICS RESURGENT AND
THEY DID THIS ANALYSIS SO IT'S
ON OUR WEBSITE. AS YOU CAN SEE
THE CITY BY CITY WHERE THE
UNDERCOUNT WAS IN NINETEEN
NINETY WHERE WE INVEST IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THE THE INCREASE SO.
I KNOW FOR THAT WAS FOR TWO
THOUSAND SO FOR TWO THOUSAND TEN
WE DIDN'T DO MUCH BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE A DOLLARS SO THAT
MIGHT BE WHAT YOU'RE REFERRING
BACK TO. BUT WE ONLY HAD TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN A TWO
THOUSAND TEN. AND SO WE NEED TO
SHIP IT TO THE TOP TWELVE OUR
HARDEST ACCOUNT COUNTIES AND
THEN THEY DISTRIBUTE FROM THERE
I THINK THAT'S WHICH CHAIRS A
GETTING TO. GIVE US SOME
RATIONALE FOR WHY WE NEED TO PUT
MORE MONEY.
IN THIS TO GET IT DONE.
I THINK JUST TO ADD ONE OF THAT
BOTH REPORTS FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND TEN HAVE.
FLAG THE ISSUE OF STARTING TO
THE EIGHT AS A PLATFORM LEARNED.
LIKE THE COMPLETE CAO
COMMITTEES BOTH TIMES STARTED
I'M. LIKE TWENTY THOUSAND
STARTING NOVEMBER NINETEEN I'M
AND THE SUCH AS OF APRIL TWO
THOUSAND TO DEFLECT.
SIX MONTHS TO WORK WITH AND THEN
IN IN TWENTY TEN BACK THE
COMPANY STARTED IN JUNE TWO
THOUSAND NINE AGAIN JUST BE EAT
LESS THAN A YEAR PRIOR TO THE
SENSE THAT SAID THERE'S VERY
LITTLE TIME. TO STRATEGIZE AND
DEPLOY.
AND SO I THINK.
THAT WAS THE KEY MASS AND I FOR
ALL OF US TO GET TOGETHER SOONER
WORK TOGETHER MORE CLOSELY THAN
WE EVER HAVE BEFORE BECAUSE IT
IS A MUTUAL INTEREST TO ALL OF
US AND TO STRATEGIZING. AND THAT
I THINK WE TOOK THAT SERIOUSLY
AND WE'VE AND WE STARTED WITH
THE LOOK OF PROCESS IN AND
BUILDING THAT AND. THE LOOK AT
DIFFERENT VOTERS HAVE AND LATE
TWENTY SIXTEEN FOR FOUR YEARS
AND IT. IN ADVANCE OF THE FACETS
OF SUCH THINK ABOUT HOW TO GET
THE DATA ON YOU HOUSING
CALIFORNIA. ANOTHER IMPORTANT
FROM
TO GET HIM FOR YEARS ADVANCE GET
GET THE BALL ROLLING.
SO I THINK ANOTHER LESSON
LEARNED WOULD BE.
THE COORDINATION WITH THE U. S.
CENSUS BUREAU DOING IT EARLIER.
WERE HEAD OF THE CENSUS BUREAU
RIGHT NOW THEY AND LITERALLY
HAVE LIKE FOUR PARTNERSHIP
SPECIALIST ACROSS THE STATE FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO WE'RE STARTING WERE SO
FAR AHEAD OF THEM THAT THEY'RE
KIND OF YOU KNOW TRYING TO PLAY
CATCH UP WITH US.
ALL AND HOPEFULLY THEY'LL HIRE
PEOPLE IN NOVEMBER OF THIS
NOVEMBER.
SO SO ON THAT FRIGHTENED DO THIS
YOU MENTION THIS IN YOUR
COMMENTS BUT WE ASK SOMEBODY
FROM THE US CENSUS BUREAU IN DC
TO COME OUT AND SPEAK WITH US
TODAY.
AND ON UNFORTUNATELY THEY THEY
DECLINED OUR INVITATION.
SO WE HOPE THAT.
THEY'LL BE BETTER COORDINATION
WITH THEM MOVING FORWARD.
BUT YOU YOU ALSO MENTION THAT
THEY'RE QUITE BEHIND.
JUST HERE CALIFORNIA THEY ALSO
QUITE BEHIND AND IN THE ENTIRE
PROCESS WHAT CAN WE DO TO FILL
GAPSTHAT THEY'RE LEAVING. YEAH
UNFORTUNATELY THEY RUN THE
CENSUS AND WE CAN TAKE OVER THAT
BUT BUT ARE THE YOU KNOW IF
THERE ARE AREAS WHERE YOU SEE
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT THAT THEY'RE
NOT THAT MEETING THEIR THEIR
CALENDAR IN THEIR TIMELINE ON
THINGS.
YEAH TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU LET
US KNOW IF IF THERE WAYS THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT YOU. ON TO IT TO
FILL THOSE GAPS THAT THERE'D.
LIKELY GONNA LEAVE OUR
COMMUNITIES.
.
ANY OTHER COLLEAGUES HAVE GOT A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
BUT UMPS YES A GO GO FOR NOW YOU
BELIEVE.
SO I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION
IS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
STRATEGIES THAT WORK AND THEN
WORK WE CERTAINLY CAN LOOK AT
PREVIOUS SENSES.
THEIR SOME THINGS ARE DIFFERENT
THE ONLINE.
IS THERE SOME THOUGHT ABOUT.
DOING WHY YELL PRACTICE RUNS ARE
DRY RUNS.
I REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW WE
GIVEN THE INFORMATION THAT WE DO
HAVE TO TO TEST DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES AND DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE AFTER ALL YOU KNOW
PRACTICE PRACTICE PRACTICE RIGHT
AND THEN WHEN THE REAL THING
COMES.
ABOUT THAT.
ABOUT TESTING DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES AND DOING SOME DRY
RUNS IN DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES TO
SEE HOW DIFFERENT.
EFFORTS MAY WORK OUT.
SO RIGHT NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
MESSAGE TESTING ON COORDINATION
GROUP ARE THAT HAS MANY OF THE
FOLKS THAT YOU'RE GONNA COME UP
UP AND SPEAK IN OTHERS. ON THAT
ARE ALREADY DOING MESSAGE
TESTING OUT IN THE FIELD.
SO THAT'S REALLY THE FIRST THING
AND OF COURSE THE FIRST ONE AND
WE DO IN WAVES THE FIRST WAVE OF
MESSAGING MRS TESTING RIGHT NOW
IS GOING TO BE TRUE DIFFERENT
THAN A YEAR FROM NOW. SO WE ARE
HEAD THE US CENSUS BUREAU IS
DOING WHAT THEY CALL SEE BANDS
CENSUS BARRIERS ATTITUDES AND
MOTIVATORS AND CONSIDERING IT
NATIONALLY AND THEY HAVE A FEW
FOCUS GROUPS HERE.
BUT THEY'RE NOT GETTING INTO
THE GRANULARITY THAT WE NEED FOR
OUR COMMUNITIES SO MANY OF THE
PARTNERS WERE ALREADY WORKING
WITH ARE DOING THAT NECESSARY
STING. I'M IN TERMS OF SORT OF
DRESS REHEARSAL WE CAN'T REALLY
DRESS REHEARSED THE OPERATIONS A
ONE WE'RE NOT EVEN SURE WHAT THE
QUESTIONS ARE GOING TO BE
BECAUSE THE HASN'T BEEN
COMPLETED. I DID DO A BETA TEST
OF THE ONLINE AND INTERNET
SUFFER SPOTS TOOL LAST APRIL. OF
THE USER EXPERIENCE LEFT
A LOT TO BE DESIRED SO I THINK
IN ARE CONVENING AS WE CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT. AND THE PEOPLE WE
ARE OPEN UP UKIAH AND READING
THEIR LIKE HOW DO WE GET ACTUAL
PAPER FORM. LIKE IT'S GREAT THAT
IT'S ONLINE BUT CERTAINLY IS
LIKE I WANT TO BE PERFORMED.
AND SO YOU KNOW THEY'RE BEING
VERY CREATIVE TO SAY THE SUCH AS
PRO SO YOU KNOW YOU CAN JUST
CALL AND ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ON
THE PHONE WELL I DON'T EASE OF
MY MINUTES. BUT YOU CAN ACTUALLY
JUST CALL THEY HUNDRED NUMBER
AND GET THEM TO SEND YOU UP FOR
SO WE'RE STARTING TO THINK ABOUT
THAT WERE HAVING GREAT
CONVERSATIONS OUT THE COMMUNITY.
ABOUT WHAT WORKS IN THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE ANSWERS
COME FROM WORSE IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES I CAN'T MAKE IT UP
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP RIGHT. SO
IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT TO BE OUT
THERE.
SO.
SO I'M REALLY HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I WAS GONNA ASK
AROUND MESSAGING INVEST TESTING.
AND SO IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE IF WE'RE GONNA
THE SPENDING THEY ARE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON OUR
REGION COMMUNICATION AND AND
KIND OF STATEWIDE MESSAGING AND
AND. DIFFERENT MESSAGING TO
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
TESTING THAT AHEAD OF TIME TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT ACTUALLY GIVES
PEOPLE THAT SECURITY. TO
PARTICIPATE.
AS OPPOSED TO JUST KIND OF
GUESSING.
IS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU KNOW FOLKS
OUT IN THE FIELD THEIR TESTING
MESSAGES THERE FEEDING THAT BACK
UP AS YOUR ALL. TEARING ACROSS
ORGANIZATIONS YOU CAN GREAT.
AYE I KNOW DOCTOR PAN.
EMPHASIZED AT THE BUDGET AND
YOU KNOW I JUST WANT TO DO THAT
AS WELL I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW. WE
DON'T WANT TO BE FRIVOLOUS WITH
OUR SURPLUS AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO SPEND SURPLUS DOLLARS ON ONE
TIME EXPENDITURES THERE IS NO
ONE TIME EXPENDITURE THAT'S
GOING TO HAVE A. HIGHER RETURN
ON INVESTMENT IN THE CENSUS.
YEAH AND THEN YOU ON THE
NUMBERS BUT IN THIS WILL BE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR
THE NEXT DECADE.
IF THERE'S IF THERE'S A LARGE
UNDERCOUNT SO AS SOON AS WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT. IN A WORLD
TALKING WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING OUR OUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE BUDGET COMMITTEES TO.
IN A PUSH FOR AS LARGE OF A A
DOLLAR NUMBER IS POSSIBLE AND I
THINK YOU ARE CBO COMMUNITY ARE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY NEEDS A
LITTLE I KNOW THIS IS JUST. YOU
YOU.
THE FIRST YEAR THERE REALLY A
SECOND THIRD YEAR DEPENDING ON
ON HE'S BEEN INVOLVED IN A MULTI
YEAR PROCESS BUT THE CBO
COMMUNITY NEED SOME CERTAINTY.
IF THEY'RE GONNA MAKE THE HIRES
YOU KNOW THAT THOSE ARE GOING TO
BE PEOPLE THAT. ARE GONNA BE ON
STAFF FOR TWO YEARS OR TWO AND A
HALF YEARS AS OPPOSED TO.
YOU KNOW JUST KIND OF THE YEAR
BY YEAR BUDGETING THAT HAVING
WORKED FOR NONPROFIT THAT I KNOW
THAT.
THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
TYPICALLY DOES SO THAT WE KNOW
WE WANT TO GIVE THEM THAT
CERTAINTY.
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE FUNDING
THERE FOR THIS EFFORT THROUGH
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
SIR DID YOU TALKED A BIT ABOUT
THE CONVERSATIONS I'VE BEEN
HAPPENING AT THE REGIONAL
MEETINGS I KNOW YOU'RE. MAYBE
THIRTY OR FORTY PERCENT OF THE
WAY THROUGH THAT THE NUMBER OF
MEETINGS WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE I
DON'T TO CREATE A LOT OF EXTRA
WORK. BEFORE THE SELECT
COMMITTEES TO GET JUST AN UPDATE
WHEN YOU HIT THAT MIDWAY POINT
OR SOON AFTER THE MIDWAY POINT.
OF HOW THOSE HOW THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING AND IF WE.
ARE DISTRICT OFFICES NEED TO
HELP MORE IN DRIVING THE RIGHT
PEOPLE THERE YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHAT. WE WANT TO DO IS WE WANT
TO FIGHT HERE HOW IT'S GOING IN
THE DISSEMINATE OUR COLLEAGUES
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN. YOU MAKE
THAT EXPERIENCE MORE MEANINGFUL
AND AND AND BETTER.
YEAH I HAVE A POINT WHERE I AND
NUMBER EIGHT TOMORROW AND SO
PROBABLY BY RIGHT AFTER THE JUNE
FIRST AFTER WE MEET MEN WITH
MOUNTAIN VIEW. A WILL HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF A BREATHER ACTION
AT THIS
SIXTH AND SEVENTH WILL HAVE
SOMETIME AFTER JUNE SIXTH
SEVENTH TO. TAKE BUT I'LL TELL
YOU YOU'RE JUST OFFICES HAVE
BEEN GREAT CAR AND NEED OTHER IT
WE'RE DOING A SHORT TIME FRAME
BECAUSE WE'RE FAST AND FURIOUS
BUT.
THEY'RE GETTING THE RIGHT
PEOPLE THERE PERFECT PERFECT.
.
AND THAT I DE ANYTHING ELSE THAT
EITHER BECAUSE WHEN I ASK YOU
ANOTHER QUESTION OR YEAH THINGS
THAT YOU WANT US TO KNOW ABOUT.
NO WE RUSSIA THROUGH THE SLIDES
NO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP WE REALLY AYE TH YOU
KNOW AGAIN THIS IS AN ALL HANDS
ON DECK I. JUST ABSOLUTELY GET
TASK THAT WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COOPERATION AND LET ME JUST
QUICKLY SAY BEFORE MOVE TO THE
NEXT PANEL YEAH I'VE MET IN THE
SET A COUPLE OF OTHER.
CONVERSATIONS THAT DOCTOR PAN
AND I'VE HAD IT WHERE.
AND THERE'S SO MUCH INTEREST IN
OUR COMMUNITIES I TALK TO MY.
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
YOU KNOW THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE AND HELP OUT AND AND
HERE LET THEIR PATIENTS KNOW I
TALK.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT NONPROFIT
IN THE DISTRICT AND I BUT I
BROUGHT THIS UP IN THIS AT ALL
YEAH WE'RE GOING TO THAT MEETING
ON JUNE FIRST AMOUNT YOU SO THEY
ARE YOU KNOW ABOUT IT IN THEIR
IN THEIR PLAN TO PARTICIPATE.
YOU'RE IN MIGHT MIGHT DREAM IS
FOR YOU KNOW BY THE TIME WE GET
TO APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY. EVERY
CBO EVERY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY EVERY LIBRARY EVERY
SCHOOL. HAS LIKE A POSTER WHEN
YOU WALK THROUGH THE FRONT DOOR
THAT SAYS PARTICIPATE IN THE
CENSUS AND IT'S DESIGNED YOU
KNOW AND AND AND KIND OF THE
RIGHT COLOR AND AND ALL THIS
KIND OF STUFF. NOT SO THAT IT
JUST BECOME UBIQUITOUS AND AND
PARTICIPATING THE CENSUS IS IN A
SCARY THING IT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW. EVERYBODY THINKS
THAT EVERYONE ELSE IS DOING AND
OF COURSE I TO DO THAT.
AND SO LET US KNOW HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT YOU ALL AND IN ACHIEVING
THAT GOAL OF JUST MAKING IT LIKE
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING I
SHOULD BE I GOT HIM A FLU SHOT
AGO. VILLA THE SENSES.
I WOULD HAVE RATE OF TO THAT IS.
FUTURE TODAY TODAY.
BUT YOU KNOW IT IS IT'S IT'S
JUST KIND OF THE SOMETHING
THAT'S THAT'S NORMAL AND
NORMALLY AT EXACTLY SO ON THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH THINK IF YOU
HAVING US.
DO DO WE HAVE.
YEAH SO WOULD LIKE TO MOVE ON TO
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT PANEL.
GREAT.
AND WE GOT DOROTHEA PARK
MANAGER AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE AT
MANAGER OF THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICE OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. AND CAROLYN COLE MEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE.
READY WHEN YOU ARE THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMEN.
BERMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE CENSUS
SELECT COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
DOROTHEA PARK REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I'M THE MANAGER. OF
THE CENSUS FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY'S CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICE
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PART OF
TODAY'S CONVERSATION ABOUT
PREPARING FOR THE CENSUS.
WHILE FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDS
OUR DETERMINE AND DISTRIBUTED IN
LARGE MEASURE BY CENSUS DRIVE
DATA ULTIMATELY IT IS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THROUGH THEIR
DIVERSE WORKFORCE OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF EMPLOYEES AND
ROBUST INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT
PROVIDE THE ON THE GROUND
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WE PROVIDE THE ESSENTIAL
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR ALL
OUR RESIDENTS FURTHERMORE IT IS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT HAS THE
CAPACITY TO ORGANIZE AND PARTNER
WITH ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
AGENCIES AS WELL AS KEY
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS TO
PROMOTE PARTICIPATION IN THE
CENSUS.
SO HOW IS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
TAKING ON THIS MONUMENTAL TASK.
WELL FIRST WE ARE THE FIRST OUT
OF THE GATE.
WE'RE HERE TO GIVE YOU A
SNAPSHOT
OF OUR EFFORTS TODAY.
WE STARTED WITH THE CREATION OF
THREE COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEES.
ONE THAT FOCUSED ON FOCUSES ON
COUNTIES REGION WIDE EFFORTS.
AND THEN TWO OTHER COMPLETE
CAMPOUT COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEES THAT FOCUS ON COUNTY
CENSUS DERIVED FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM AREAS.
CURRENTLY THE COUNTY WIDE
OUTREACH CCC THAT WE CALL LEAD
WITH THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS
BECOME A DYNAMIC EVER GROWING
INTO FIRST PARTNERSHIP THAT
INCLUDES SEVERAL SUBCOMMITTEES.
THE FIRST EVER COMMITTEE THAT WE
ORGANIZE WAS OUR STAKEHOLDER
COMMITTEE THAT WE.
PARTICIPATE AT A COMMUNITY
TABLE.
THAT THE CENSUS POLICY ADVOCATES
THE NETWORK PULLED TOGETHER WITH
THEIR PARTNERS THEIR FIFTEEN
PARTNERS AND WE FOCUS ON A BROAD
RANGE OF ETHNIC COMMUNITIES AS
WELL AS THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY LOW
INCOME POPULATIONS CHILDREN.
THOSE LIVING WITH DISABILITY
SENIORS AND THE HOMELESS.
WITH THE RECENT ADDITION OF THIS
IS CITIZENSHIP STATUS QUESTION
THE FOCUS ON OUR IMMIGRANT
POPULATIONS ARE BECOMING
PARAMOUNT.
WE JOIN BUT THE CITY. AND OZ WE
ARE SPONSORING WITHIN LA O. A
CONVENING ON IMMIGRATION
TOMORROW.
AS WELL AS.
WE'VE HAD A COMPETING WITH
LATINO COMMUNITY FOUNDATION.
ALSO THE COUNTIES IMMIGRATION
TASK FORCE HAS ADDED THE CENSUS
AS A FOCUS AREA INITIATIVE FOR
THEMSELVES.
ANOTHER SUBCOMMITTEE WHICH IS
HUGE OUR OUR MUNICIPALITIES.
IN A COUNTY WITH EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES AND A HUNDRED AND FORTY
UNINCORPORATED AREAS WE HAD TO
COME TO GRIPS WITH THE FORUM
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR MEANINGFUL
CONVERSATIONS.
AND IN CASE IT WILL GO TO IDEAS.
WE'RE UTILIZING OUR SIX COUNCILS
OF GOVERNMENT.
AN AN ANTELOPE VALLEY CONSORTIUM
AS AN AVENUE TO REACH OUR CITY
MAYORS MATT CITY MANAGERS AND
CITY PLANNERS THAT'LL BE
INVESTED IN THE CENSUS.
ANOTHER SUBCOMMITTEE IS HIGHER
EDUCATION.
HIGHER EDUCATION HAS A
PARTICULARLY UNIQUE CHALLENGE
AND OPPORTUNITIES STUDENTS
REPRESENT ONE OF THE LOWEST
RESPONSE POPULATIONS COUNTY WIDE.
SO WE BROUGHT TOGETHER HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS INCLUDING
USC UCLA LOYOLA MARYMOUNT MOUNT
SAINT MARY'S OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE.
THE STATE COLLEGES AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND WE'VE INCLUDED BOTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND STUDENTS TO
DISCUSS.
AND EXPLORE A WIDE RANGE OF
SOLUTIONS.
AT INCLUDING USING COLLEGE
ADDRESSES AS THE RESIDENTS
ADDRESS FOR HOMELESS STUDENTS.
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
REPRESENT THIRD THIRTY PERCENT
OF THEIR STUDENT BODY. IS
HOMELESS THEIR LIVING EITHER ON
COUCHES COUCH SURFING OR IN CARS
VEHICLES.
WHERE I'M LOOKING AT PROVIDING
INTERNSHIP OR VOLUNTEER CREDIT
FOR STUDENTS TO ENGAGE THEM A
CENSUS GOODWILL AMBASSADORS?
WE'RE UTILIZING STUDENT
GOVERNMENT FRATERNITIES AND
SORORITIES COUNSELORS AND
FACULTIES AS MESSENGERS.
INCLUDING THE SENSE IS THIS PART
OF THE ONLINE CLASS REGISTRATION
SO THEY HAVE TO OPT.
IN TWO THE CENSUS AND RESPOND.
WHEN THEY GO TO REGISTER THEIR
VEHICLES FOR PARKING. WHICH IS
IMPORTANT TO STUDENT GROUPS.
ESPECIALLY AT SOME OF OUR
CAMPUSES. THEY TOO WILL HAVE TO
SEE AND PARTICIPATE AND BE A
PART OF THE MESSAGING OF THE
CENSUS.
WHERE WE'RE TAKING ALL OF THE
ONLINE PART OF PORTALS AND WEB
SITES THAT THE UNIVERSITIES HAVE
BEEN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT?
WE'RE CREATE RICK TALKING ABOUT
CREATING FRIENDLY COMPETITIONS
THROUGH THE ARTS.
AND WORKING WITH DEPARTMENTS
THAT EDUCATE FUTURE NURSES
PUBLIC HEALTH ADMINISTRATORS AND
SOCIAL WORKERS.
TO CONSIDER A MODULE IN THEIR
LECTURES.
AND WE'RE ALSO PARTNERING WITH
USE U. S. CENSUS BUREAU TO
PROVIDE JOB OPPORTUNITIES WHICH
ARE CRITICAL FOR A SPECIALLY IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND LA
TRADE TACK AND AREAS SUCH AS
THAT.
OUR NEXT PARTNER THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THAT WE JUST
STARTED WITH IS LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THIS DISTRICT REACHES OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
BETWEEN K. THROUGH TWELVE AND WE
HAVE THIRTY ONE OF OUR CITIES.
THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEY ALSO HAVE A
DAHLE PROGRAMS AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
THIS IS AN ENORMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE CAN
UTILIZE IN OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS.
WERE LOOKING AT EXPANDING THEIR
WE ARE ONE LA UNIFIED CAMPAIGN.
WHICH THEY'VE USED FOR THEIR
DOCKET STUDENTS TO INCLUDE THE
SENSES AS WELL AS OTHER DISTRICT
WIDE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMATIC
EFFORTS.
ALONG WITH THE STUDENT AND
PARENT SENSES COULD WELL
AMBASSADOR VOLUNTEER
OPPORTUNITIES.
THE CITY THE COUNTY AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVE ALREADY
AGREED TO SCHEDULE A HALF DAY
WORKSHOP IN JUNE. TO BRAINSTORM
IDEAS AROUND CENSUS OUTREACH.
NOT BE AND THAT INCLUDES HOW WE
WILL EXPAND TO OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BEYOND LA UNIFIED.
VERY RECENT WE ALSO HAVE TO
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS THAT WE ARE
REALLY ADVOCATING ONE THERE ARE
IS SENT CENSUS ACTION KIOSKS.
WE PLAN TO ASK DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES TO SET ASIDE SPACE IN
PUBLIC FACILITIES TO ALLOW FOR
THE SET UP OF HIS SENSES ACTION
HE ASKED. WHERE THE PUBLIC CAN
VISIT HIM FILL OUT ONLINE CENSUS
SURVEYS?
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THAT THE
QUESTION ASSISTANCE CENTERS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
LAST GO AROUND ARE GOING TO BE
TRANSFORMED INTO JUST MOBILE
UNITS WERE TALKING ABOUT NOT
HAVING. SOMEBODY HAVE TO RESPOND
TO A MOBILE UNIT BETWEEN TWO AND
FOUR AND WE'RE FINE WITH MOBILE
UNITS BUT ALSO HAVE A STATIONARY
LOCATION WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
THAT THEY CAN REACH.
WE ALSO ARE ASKING THAT%
VOLUNTEERS GOOD WILL SENSE HE
SAID PASSERS BE TRAIN TO
OFFICIALLY ASSIST WITHOUT
REACHING ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THE COUNTY HAS NUMEROUS
VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS WE INTENDED
TAP INTO THOSE AS WELL AS STU AS
WE MENTIONED EARLIER THE
STUDENTS.
WE'VE ALSO.
TALK TO YOU OUR UNIONS.
THEY'VE EXPRESSED A STRONG
INTEREST IN ENGAGING IN THE
COUNTY CENSUS PLANNING PROCESS
AND OUR FIRST MET MEETINGS WITH
THE UNIONS.
THERE COMPETING RIGHT NOW TO GET
TO ME FIRST. BUT THEY'LL BE IN
JUNE.
I PROMISE.
I HOME AND THEN WE ALSO HELD A
HACKATHON.
THAT THIS CITY AND THE COUNTY
IS PART OF THE LA CITY PUBLIC
LIBRARY'S DIGITAL INCLUSION WEEK.
IT DREW PEOPLE FROM THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTY.
AND WE EVEN HAD VIRTUAL PROP
PARTICIPATION FROM THE COUNTRY
OF COLOMBIA.
AND THEY SPENT THE DAY WITH US
LOOKING AT CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR RESIDENTS TO
RESPOND AT THE CENSUS. AND THE
WINNING TEAM DEVELOPED TO SERIES
OF APPS FOR THE CENSUS ACTION HE
ASKS.
COUNTY ALSO HAS THE TWO OTHER
COMPLETE CAO COMMITTEES HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES IS ONE AND
THE OTHER IS TRANSPORTATION.
WITH THE PRIMARY RESPONSIBILITY
OF MESSAGING AROUND THE BROAD
SPECTRUM OF COUNTY PROP PROGRAMS
OFFERED TO COUNTY RESIDENTS.
THAT ARE FUNDED THROUGH FEDERAL
AND STATE REVENUES.
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION WHY WHY
AND I FEELING OUT THE CENSUS.
AND IT'S CRITICAL FOR RESIDENTS
AND WHITES CRITICAL FOR THE MISS
RESIDENTS TO PARTICIPATE.
FINALLY WE WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE STATE CENSUS OPERATION AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ATTENDING THE
CONVENIENCE THAT WILL BE IN LA
COUNTY AND WE HOPE TO ADD AN
EXTRA ONE.
FOR OUR RESIDENTS IN THE
ANTELOPE VALLEY THAT'S A PLUG.
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS WILL
REQUIRE ACCOUNTABILITY FROM OUR
PARTNERS.
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES ARE
CURRENTLY PREPARING RIGHT NOW
OBJECTIVES AND STRATEGY PLANTS
BASED ON ANALYSIS OF THE LOW
RESPONSE SQUARE BLOCK GROUPS
UTILIZING THE COUNTY'S MAPPING
TOOL. SO THE CENSUS BUREAU HAS A
MAPPING TOOL AT THE CENSUS TRACK
LEVEL WE DEVELOPED ONE AT THE
BLOCK GROUP LEVEL SO THAT WE CAN
GET MORE DETAILED INFORMATION.
WE ALSO HAVE QUARTERLY STATUS
WORK PLANS THAT IDENTIFY
ACTIVITIES THAT WE'RE GONNA MORE
BE WORKING ON THE CHALLENGES
WERE FACING.
STATUS AND NEXT STEPS AS WE
APPROACH THE CENSUS
WE ROLL OUT ACT AND THEN WE PLAN
TO ROLL OUT ACTIVITY AND EVENT
CALENDARS.
ALL OF THESE PLANNING DOCUMENTS
HAVE BEEN SHARED WITH THE U. S.
CENSUS BUREAU WHO THEY ARE USING
THOSE MATRIALS TO TRAIN THE
REST OF THE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE.
.
I WANNA MOVE ON BECAUSE OF TIME
HERE.
.
AND IN CLOSING ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS AND PARTNERSHIPS REQUIRE
RESOURCES.
SO ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
COUNTY'S REQUEST FOR INCREASED
FUNDING FOR LOCAL COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEES ARE ANTICIPATED NEED
ALONE IS MINIMALLY TWELVE
MILLION. TO CARRY OUT THE
STRATEGIES AND WORK PLANS AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN IN ADDRESSING
ESPECIALLY IN ADDRESSING THIS TO
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION.
BASED ON THE COUNTIES TWENTY TEN
BEST PRACTICES AND CURRENT
PLANNING EXPERIENCE IT'S THE
COUNTY'S POSITION THAT WE MUST
BE INCLUSIVE AND OPEN TO THE
BROADEST RANGE OF PARTNERS THAT
ARE EAGER TO PARTICIPATE. IN
COUNTING EACH AND EVERY RESIDENT
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE
IS NO ONE SINGLE GOVERNMENT
AGENCY OR STAKEHOLDER THAT CAN
TAKE ON THIS ENORMOUS TASK ALONE
AND IT'S IMPERATIVE. THAT WE ALL
WORK AND SHARE IDEAS NEW
CONCEPTS AND APPROACHES TO REACH
AND ULTIMATELY SERVE ALL OF OUR
DESERVING CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HIS COLEMAN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CAROLYN COLEMAN I AS SERVE AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND.
A PROUD MEMBER OF THE COMPLETE
COUNT COMMITTEE I THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME TODAY AS WE'VE HEARD
THIS MORNING ALREADY A FAIR AND
ACCURATE CENSUS. IS IMPORTANT
FOR MANY REASONS FIRST IT HELPS
SUPPORT OUR POLITICAL
REPRESENTATION IN WASHINGTON A
WHICH IS IS EVER IMPORTANT AND
IT ALSO SERVES AS THE THE BASIS.
FOR THE FORMULAS THAT ARE USED
TO RETURN OUR DOLLARS BACK TO
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT JUST ONE OF THOSE
PROGRAMS TODAY AND. AND REALLY
UP SORT OF HIT HOME ON WHY THIS
MATTER SO MUCH TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A GOOD EXAMPLE IS
THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
CD BEACHY I KNOW I HAVE SOME
FORMER. LOCAL OFFICIALS ON THIS
PANEL WHO ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THAT PROGRAM.
CBG DOLLARS GO TO CITIES WITH AT
LEAST FIFTY THOUSAND POPULATION
AND COUNTIES OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND THEY RECEIVE A DIRECT
ALLOCATION OF THE CBG FUNDS. AND
FOR THE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS
THERE'S A SET ASIDE AT THE STATE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES RECEIVED
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN CD BG FUNDING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE VARIOUS CHANNELS.
AND THAT AMOUNTS TO ABOUT TEN
PERCENT OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
CITY BG THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALLOCATED PERIOD IN
THE COUNTRY SO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IS WHAT
IT'S WORTH TO US. ANNUALLY.
THIS PROGRAM IS THE MOST
FLEXIBLE FORM OF ASSISTANCE THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES RECEIVE IT
IS USED TO SUPPORT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. INITIATIVES
AS WELL OF JOB AS JOB TRAINING
PROGRAMS WHICH I KNOW ARE ALL
IMPORTANT PRIORITIES FOR THE
STATE AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND FOR THESE REASONS CITY
OFFICIALS ARE VERY KEEN AND DO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT THEY PLAY IN THE CENSUS
UNDERTAKING.
WERE ALSO KEENLY AWARE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS AS.
MY COLLEAGUE HAS REFER TO SOME
OF THE NEW VULNERABILITIES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS YOUR SENSES
NEW QUESTIONS NEW TECHNOLOGY ON
IN PLACE AS WELL AS IN THIS
STATE. OTHER HOUSING CRISIS
WHICH CAN MAKE ADDRESSES OF VERY
VERY DIFFICULT THAT WILL ONLY
MAKE IT MORE CHALLENGING AND
MORE IMPORTANT THAT OUR
RESOURCES ARE COORDINATED SO
THAT WE HAVE A ROBUST. UP OUT OF
THE BOX APPROACH
ACCOUNTING EVERYONE IN TWENTY
TWENTY.
SO WHAT ROLE WILL CITIES PLAY
FIRST THROUGH THE LOCAL UPDATE
OF CENSUS ADDRESSES PROGRAM OR
LUKA AS YOU'VE HEARD. CITIES
WILL HELP MAKE SURE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS THE BEST
ADDRESSES THAT WE CAN PROVIDE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO EVERYONE CAN
BE COUNTED.
AND WITH NEW HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AND HOPEFULLY MORE
THAT ARE IN THE PIPELINE. OF OUR
ROLE IN HELPING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT UNDERSTAND THESE
ADDRESSES AND WHERE THEY ARE
WILL BE VERY IMPORTANT.
SECOND CITY OFFICIALS CAN HELP
EDUCATE AND RAISE THE AWARENESS
BY THEIR RESIDENTS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CENSUS
ENCOURAGE THEM TO RESPOND VIA
QUESTIONNAIRE BY DIALING EIGHT
HUNDRED NUMBER IN GETTING A FORM.
AND THE MANY OTHER WAYS THAT
WE'VE HEARD SHARE TODAY. AND
THEN FINALLY I WANT TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DID AND TWENTY TEN. THE
LEAGUE WILL BE USING ITS VARIOUS
MEDIA CHANNELS AND ITS REGIONAL
PUBLIC AFFAIRS NETWORK TO SERVE
AS A CONDUIT OF INFORMATION TO
CITY OFFICIALS AROUND THE STATE
REGARDING THE EFFORT. AND WE
KNOW WHAT YOU KNEW NO IS THAT
EVERY CITY IS DIFFERENT EVERY
REGION IS DIFFERENT AND ALL WE
WANT TO BE SURE TO GET. THE BEST
IDEAS OUT THERE AND LET THEM
TAILOR THE SOLUTIONS ARE TO FIT
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IN CLOSING CALIFORNIA CITIES
LOOK FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH
THE STATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH THE PARTNERS WHO
YOU'LL HEAR FROM US SHORTLY AND
OTHERS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE COUNTED THAT
WERE ONLY COUNTED ONCE. AND THAT
WERE COUNTED IN THE RIGHT PLACE
BANKING I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS COLEMAN.
WANTED OPEN UP THE COLLEAGUES
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
THEY HAVE.
I ONCE GOT SEAN.
WELL I HAVE A COUPLE A.
QUESTIONS AND IN COMMENTS ON
COLEMAN YOU MENTIONED. THE
IMPORTANCE OF CITIES AND AND
ALSO THE LOCAL PROCESS AND.
I NEXT WENT TO ONE OF MY CITIES
I IN MY DISTRICT WHERE.
WE'D TRIED TO THE I INSTRUCTED
MY DISTRICT STAFF TO REACH OUT
TO ALL THE CITIES AND CITY
MANAGERS TO LET THEM KNOW ABOUT
THE LOCAL PROCESS AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. UMD AND THEN.
DIED FOUND OUT I I KIND OF HEARD
THAT ONE OF MY CITIES HAD
DECLINED TO PARTICIPATE AT FIRST
THEY THEY SAID THEY'RE GOING TO
AND THEN WHEN SOME OF THE
COUNCILMEMBERS HER TO WAIT WAIT
BE WALKING THROUGH NEIGHBORHOODS.
WITH CLIP BOARDS YOU KNOW
COUNTING LOOKING IT OVER
PEOPLE'S FENCES AND COUNTING YOU
KNOW THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF OF.
THE UNTRADITIONAL. HOUSING
UNITS THAT MIGHT EXIST PET FREE
THAT SCARE THEM.
AND AND RIGHTFULLY SO I MEAN
YOU KNOW THIS DAY AND AGE.
IT'S THEM THESE NEIGHBORHOODS I
KNOW A LOT OF THOSE RESIDENTS
ARE GONNA HAVE A LOT OF FEAR IF
THEY SEE SOMEBODY YOU KNOW
LOOKING THROUGH FENCES AND AND.
HAVE MAKING NOTES AND THEY'RE
WORRIED IS THE INFORMATION TO BE
USED FOR FOR.
YET TODAY FOR CODE ENFORCEMENT
AND MAYBE SOME OTHER THINGS.
AND SO WHAT KIND OF
COMMUNICATION HAVE YOU BEEN
DOING IN THAT WAS AS MUCH MY
FAULT AS ANYBODY'S FOR NOT
REACHING OUT TO QUICKLY CALLED
SOME THE COUNCILMEMBERS TO
EXPLAIN TO THEM THE OF THE
PROCESS HOW IMPORTANT WAS AND.
AND THE SAFETY OF THAT
INFORMATION BUT.
HAS THOUGH THE LEAGUE BEEN CUT
YOU ARE TRYING TO PUSH
INFORMATION AND MAKING SURE
REALLY THAT.
PEOPLE ARE PAYING ATTENTION
BECAUSE I KNOW WHEN I WAS ON THE
CITY COUNCIL WE INUNDATED WITH
WITH INFO.
AND SOMETIMES YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S IMPORTANT AND WHAT ISN'T.
SURVEY TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE EFFORTS
ABSOLUTELY IN ALL THE
INFORMATION IT WILL BE STANDING
ON THE CENSUS WILL BE IMPORTANT
YEAH. I AGREE. TO RECEIVE YOU
YOU RAISE SOME GOOD GOOD POINTS
OF.
CHAIRMAN AND BELIEVE HAS BEEN
HAS BEEN.
PUSHING OUT INFORMATION TO OUR
MEMBERS TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
THAT THE LUKA PROCESS IS
UNDERWAY TO TALK WITH THEM ABOUT
WHO THEY CAN. CONNECT WITH THEM
CONTACT ABOUT HOW TO PARTICIPATE
AND WHAT KIND OF RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP THEM DO THAT
BUT I'LL BE HONEST WITH YOU
RAISE A VERY GOOD POINT IN TERMS
OF. THIS WHOLE NOTION OF TRUST
IN HIM IN GOVERNMENT AND I THINK
WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO TO HELP
NOT ONLY EDUCATE FOLKS. ABOUT
THE MECHANICS OF THE PROCESS BUT
ALSO THE IMPORTANCE OF THE DATA
HOW IT WILL BE USED AND HOW WILL
NOT BE USEDYET SO WE'VE GOT
MORE WORK MORE WORK TO DO THERE.
THE IS THAT YOUR CARRY YEAH I
JUST DONE ON ME.
ONE OF THINGS LIKE AT. ALL OF
THE MEMBERS WHAT ABOUT THE NON
MEMBER CITY SINCE OUR WAY THAT
WE CAN HELP REACH OUT IN SOME
WAY BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE'S
PLENTY THAT. DO NOT PARTICIPATE
IN ONLY A CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND
DID HAVE YOU THOUGHT OF COURSE
MY IDEAS OF HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO DO SO. AND CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME AYE RURAL AREAS.
THEY ALWAYS SAY WE NEVER GET
ANYTHING WE DON'T GET ANYTHING
FOR IT ON THE TABLE AND THEY
DON'T WANT TO BE THERE SO. HAS
THERE BEEN ANY DISCUSSION ON
WHAT WE DO ABOUT NON MEMBER
CITIES.
WE WE HAVE.
AYE HANDFUL OF NON MEMBER
CITIES THAT WE CERTAINLY CAN'T
IDENTIFY AND SUPPLEMENT BEEN
OUTREACH TO THEM BUT I I THINK
THE POINT YOU YOU REYES ALSO. A
SPEAKS TO NATIVE AND NON ENGAGED
MEMBER THAT PERSON DOESN'T OPEN.
THE THAT THAT THE TEMPE MALE OR
THE TWENTIETH EMAIL THAT MIGHT
COME TO THEM.
WE HAVE NOT CITED ANY SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES YET TO A BETTER
ENGAGE THEM.
BUT I ASSURE YOU THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE ON MY LIST.
I FIND THIS HEARING IS GOOD
POINT AND AND IF THERE'S A WAY
TO TO. LET ALL OF US KNOW WHICH
CITIES IN OUR DISTRICTS AREN'T
MEMBERS I DON'T KNOW THE BEST
WAY TO DO THAT WOULD BE WE CAN
THEN REACH OUT TO THEM ALSO
BECAUSE IT AYE THAT I KNEW
REALIZE THAT. AND THAT'S A GREAT
POINT.
WHERE IF THE NON THE LESS THAN
NOT GETTING THE INFO THEM AND WE
CAN PUSH THAT INFO OUT TO THEM
THEN THROUGH OUR CONTACTS
ABSOLUTELY HAPPY TO DO THEM
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I
MENTIONED THE REGIONAL? PUBLIC
AFFAIRS NETWORK THAT'S IN PLACE
THAT LOOKED AT THE LAKE SO
BESIDES THE RESOURCES PHYSICALLY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE
RESOURCES AND. A WHAT WE HAVE
DIVIDED UP.
SIXTEEN REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE WHO ARE A MORE FAMILIAR
WILL BE MORE FAMILIAR WITH WHO
IS RESPONDING WHO'S ENGAGED IN
WHO WE NEED TO REACH. AND IT
CERTAINLY REACH OUT YOUR
DISTRICT OFFICES ON TO HELP MAKE
YOU AWARE AS WELL GREAT. I THINK
AT THE AGREE THAT THOSE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS NOT JUST YOUR BUT
YEAH SEE SACCHETTI SHOULD BE
REACHING UNDER WHICH WE WORKING
TOGETHER BUT. I JUST ALWAYS HAVE
SOME OF THE CITIES THAT ARE JUST.
NON RESPONSIVE.
MY LOOK FOR YOU HELPING US.
MS PART YOU TALKED ABOUT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF AND I WAS REALLY
HEARTENED TO HEAR ABOUT HOW
CREATIVE LA.
COUNTY IS IS GETTING ERROR SIT
YOU GO COUNTY AND CITY IT SOUNDS
LIKE ARAB THEN AND THE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE TWO.
HOW ARE THEIR PLANS HOW CAN WE?
SHARE THAT INFORMATICS YOU FIND
OUT WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S
NOT HOW CAN WE.
YEAH SUFFERS THE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT TO SHARE IT TO THE OTHER
FIFTY SEVEN COUNTIES ACROSS THE
STATE.
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS PROVIDE
THE U. S. CENSUS BUREAU WITH ALL
OF OUR.
.
THEY ARE DIFFERENT TEMPLATES
MANNER USING HIM.
IN ESTABLISHING OBJECTIVES AND
STRATEGIES HOW TO DO A WORK PLAN.
AND HOW TO SET THAT UP AND ALSO
HOW TO DEVELOP ACTIVITY SHEETS
FOR DOWN THE ROAD BUT WE
ACTUALLY START ROLLING OUT
EVENTS. AT PARKS AND LIBRARIES
IN THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY.
IS SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS THAT WE
MAKE SURE WE ARE FILLING THE GAP
BETWEEN.
.
SO BASICALLY THAT IS ONE MAJOR
WAY THAT WE'RE DOING WE'RE JUST
BASICALLY SHARE EVERYTHING WITH
THE US CENSUS BUREAU WHOSE
INTERN TRAINING.
I THINK THEY'VE TRAINED A FEW
COUNTIES ALREADY AND THERE CAN
YOU. THE PRICE OF OTHER.
TRAINING TEMPLATES THAT THEY'RE
USING THAT THEY DEAD WE WEEPING
GIVING ANYBODY WHO WANTS OUR
INFORMATION IT'S IT'S AVAILABLE
TO THEM PERFECT WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
THE US CENSUS BUREAU DO YOU HAVE
A COPY DE THIS.
YEAH.
.
SORRY FOR THE UNSOLICITED PLUG.
BUT THAT'S GREAT AGAIN AS WE
DEFINITELY WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
A LOT OF THE COUNTIES DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES A. LA COUNTY HAS
AND AND DON'T HAVE A HISTORY OF
WORKING ON.
THE CENSUS THAT SO IMPORTANT SO
WE HAD YET A DIFFERENT ONE AT.
THAT TAKE AS MUCH ADVANTAGE OF
THE GOOD WORKS YOU'RE DOING IS
POSSIBLE.
AND THEN TO THE EXTENT I KNOW
THAT OUR NEXT PANEL IS GOING TO
BE ON COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FOUNDATIONS
BUT MAYBE GET THEM IF YOU THAT'S
WHY TELL US A LITTLE BIT DE. HOW
IF IF YOU'RE WORKING WITH
FOUNDATIONS OR CBO'S AND?
HOW WE CAN HELP THOSE EFFORTS
OR KIND OF WHAT PLANS YOU HAVE?
SO.
SEE PAN HAS INCLUDED US AT THE
COMMUNITY TABLE ON. A WITH THEIR
AND THEY'VE BEEN HAVING REGIONAL
TABLES AYE TO DEVELOP THEIR
GENERAL PLAN WHICH WILL BE
DISCUSSING A LITTLE BIT.
LATER.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM ON AS WELL AS
OTHERS IS IDENTIFYING GAPS NAM.
SO THEY ARE LOOKING AT.
WHERE WE'RE LITERALLY GOING
BLOCK BY BLOCK GROUP TO IDENTIFY
WHAT CAN'T COVERAGE THEY CAN
HANDLE?
WE DON'T WANT FOLKS OVER
PROMISING IN ENTER DELIVERING IN
THE END OF THE DAY THERE ARE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT CAN HELP
OUT LIKE I SAID UNIONS. COUNTY
EMPLOYEES.
SO WORTH LOOKING AT THEIR
CAPACITY WHAT'S WITHIN THEIR
CAPACITY AND THEN HOW WE CAN
HELP FILL THE GAPS
SO IT'S A IT'S IT. A COMPLETE
PICTURE AND THE COMPLETE.
WAY OF ATTACKING THE.
THE EFFORT. AND THE CAMPAIGN SO
THAT'S REALLY.
OUR PRIMARY EFFORT RIGHT NOW IS
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH THEM
AS THEY DEVELOP MORE AND MORE OF
THEIR GENERAL PLAN AND HOW THEY
WANT TO APPROACH.
OUTREACH AND AND FIGURING OUT
WITH THEM WE SEND THEM LISTS OF
CBO'S THAT WE OBTAIN FROM OUR
BOARD OFFICES FROM THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS.
AND THEY'RE NOT ALL GOING TO BE
THE PERFECT MAN AND THEY ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF OVER INTO THEIR
COMMITTED TO OTHER THINGS LIKE
THAT OUT THE VOTE.
SO THERE'S GONNA BE LIMITATIONS
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO ALL BE
PITCHING IN TOGETHER BUT WE ARE
VERY MUCH WORKING TOGETHER GREAT.
GREAT I I WOULD JUST ADD FOR THE
LEAGUE SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID IN
TWENTY TEN HOW WE WORK WITH A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY PARTNERS
THAT END. UP FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS WE WILL
REINVIGORATE OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS PER AND I WORK
ACROSS THE STATE PERFECTLY FOR
TO IT. THOUGHT WEBER.
YEAH I TOOK A QUICK QUESTION YOU
MENTIONED TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE PROJECT IN LA COUNTY.
AND THAT I GUESS THAT'S WHAT
THE TOTAL PROJECT ITSELF ALL THE
WAY UP UNTIL.
.
RIGHT TWENTY THAT'S MONEY THAT'S
MAINLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW AND WE JUST AS I HAD
ORIGINALLY THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO BE AROUND EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION BUT WITH THE IMMIGRATION
QUESTION. WERE THINKING WE'RE
GOING TO NEED TO INCREASE THAT
TO DO A MORE ROBUST OUTREACH AND
WORKING.
.
BOTH ON THE AIR IN ON THE GROUND
WITHIN GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
PARTNERING WITH OUR OTHER CBO
PARTNERS AND THAT TWELVE MILLION
IS COMING FROM WHERE AT IT
WHEREAS MEMBER THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW YEAH. WE'RE
ASKING THAT WORK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEKING FROM THE STATE
TWELVE MILLION YES AND THIS IS
IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTY. WELL
YES THIS PART OF THE FIFTY OUT
THAT BOTH TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW I TELL ALL WORK TOGETHER SO
CERTAINLY LA COUNTY. JUST FOR
THE CAN FOR LA COUNTY IS LOOKING
FOR TWELVE MILLION WHICH WILL
COME OUT OF THAT FIFTY OR
WHATEVER THE FINAL. AMOUNT IS SO
SOME OF US WANT MUCH MORE THAN
FIFTY SO IF WELL WHAT THEY'VE
HER AND SO DID I PUT IT INTO THE
DIRE IT WELL IT IS THE PER THE
CURRENT PERSPECTIVE IS. THAT THE
STATE THE GOVERNOR'S BUT
PROPOSED BUDGET HAS ONE MILLION
STATEWIDE FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND
TWO MILLION STATEWIDE FOR THE
SECOND YEAR AND WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. IS NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO DO.
TO ADDRESS LA COUNTY AND IN
PARTICULAR.
AND PROBABLY OTHER COUNTY SINCE
WELL BUT CERTAINLY FOR LA COUNTY
IT'S NOT GOOD TO ALLOW US TO DO
AS ROBUST AN EFFORT AS WE'D LIKE
TO.
HAS THERE BEEN A.
AND AND MAYBE IT IS SOMEWHERE I
HAVEN'T SEEN IT IN THE BUDGET
YET IS THEY'VE BEEN A BUDGET
* BUT GOES BEYOND THE FOR THE
FIFTY YEAH I I. AM SAYING THIS
BECAUSE EVERYBODY STILL ON THESE
NUMBERS AROUND IN THERE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A COORDINATED.
REQUEST
OF THAT INCOME THAT INCLUDES ALL
OF THE COUNTIES ALL OF THE
NUMBERS THAT I MEAN THIS STUFF
WOULD DO IN THIS.
THIS AFTERNOON IT REALLY US I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT WHAT'S THE REALLY THE COST
THAT AND THE EXPECTATION FROM
THE STATE OF THE STATE OF FOR
THE VARIOUS GROUPS THAT A
PARTICIPATING? AND WE HEARD
FIFTY IN SOME OF THE NUMBER I
CAN'T REMEMBER.
BUT.
AND I'M JUST TRYING FIGURES A
TWELVE AND FIFTY OF THIS TWELVE
IN ADDITION TO THE FIFTY OR
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE NUMBER.
YES I THINK HAVING THE STE WE
ARE STILL TRYING TO GET A THAT A
GOOD SENSE OF EXACTLY WHAT THAT
OVERALL MORE THE AND OLD THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY NEED IS.
IN TERMS OF A DOLLAR FIGURE AND
I KNOW.
I THINK THERE WAS A.
PROPOSAL FROM ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE FOR SIXTY SEVEN MILLION AT
WHICH I THINK WAS.
THE IDENTIFIED IN THE IN THE.
CAO BUDGET DOCUMENT AS AS ONE
THIRD OF THE TOTAL.
NEEDED SO THAT THE TOTAL WAS
GOING TO BE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
WAS WHAT THEY IDENTIFIED AND BUT
ONLY FUNDING A THIRD OF IT.
THAT AT THIS STAGE THAT IS
STILL BEING DISCUSSED IN THE IN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
SO THAT'S A THIS IS A LIVE
CONVERSATION.
THAT I THINK YOU ALL WILL BE
HAVING MORE.
OVER THEN GO OVER THIS WEEK.
YES PLEASE.
I.
I TRAVEL HISTORY.
QUESTION SO IN TWO THOUSAND
ODYSSEY LOS ANGELES HEAD OUT
SENSES ARE.
I JAN PERRY.
AND SHE.
DID EFFORTS IT WOULDN'T IF DO
YOU ANYBODY KNOW WHERE FUNDING
CAME FOR THAT BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
WE HAD TO SEE OF LA OTHER.
A ROBUST PROGRAM AND WE PUT A
LOT OF ENERGY AND EFFORT INTO IT.
AND I NEVER KNEW I WAS FUND I
THOUGHT IT CAME FROM THE GENERAL
FUND BUT I'M NOT.
IF YOU HAVE I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THIS HOW THE CITY FUNDED
THE BUDGET FOR FOR TWO THOUSAND.
AND ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENING THIS TIME IS A
SITTING COUNTY OR ACTUALLY
PARTNERED TOGETHER AND.
WHERE IS IN THE LAST CENSUS I
THINK THE CITY HAD ITS ROADMAP
IN THE COUNTY HAD ITS ROMANCE SO
ONE OF THE POSITIVE THINGS
THAT'S GOING ON NOW IS WE ARE
PARTNERED?
BUT I I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT THE CITY BUDGET WAS I'M I
DO YOU KNOW THAT. THE STATE
ALLOCATION TO THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN TWENTY TEN AND I
THINK IT WAS AROUND FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR ALL
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES FOR US TO
SHARE WITH ALL EIGHTEEN CITIES
SO WAS.
FAIRLY SMALL ALLOCATION BUT AND
THAT WAS TO THE FACT THAT. THE
STATE WAS IN RECESSION SO. OKAY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
PAINTED A GREAT JOB OF KEEPING
US THE ON TIME AND THEN AS SOON
AS HE HANDED OVER TO ME WE WENT
OFF TRACK.
BUT NONE THAT I KNOW THIS IS
GREAT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION.
AND AND.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT.
GROUP THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NOW WHICH IS THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND FOUNDATIONS.
AND.
FIRST WE HAVE DANIELS AND GOLLY
SENIOR VP AT HOW OF HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT. JOHN DAHLE BIRD DOBAR
TO THE US CENSUS POLICY
ADVOCATES IN NETWORKING
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF POLITICAL
VOICE AT THE ADVANCEMENT PROJECT
CALIFORNIA. ANDREA GUERRERO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALLIANCE IN DIEGO AND DANIEL
EACH IN A SAY.
PROJECT DIRECTOR DEMOGRAPHIC
RESEARCH PROJECT AT ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS
ANGELES.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US TODAY.
SURE AND.
MISUSING GOLLY IF YOU WANT TO
KICK US OFF.
SURE GOOD MORNING THANK YOU.
SOUGHT THE REASON I'M SITTING
IN THIS CHAIR IS BECAUSE THERE
ARE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT DANIEL SINGLE BUT
THERE IS NO CALIFORNIA CENSUS
FOUNDATION.
SO OTHER FOUNDATIONS LIKE OURS
OURS A HEALTH FOUNDATION.
I GOTTA FIGURE OUT HOW WE
INTERRUPT OUR NORMAL COURSE OF
BUDGETING IN BUSINESS EVERY TEN
YEARS.
HOW TO TRY TO STEP UP AS BEST WE
CAN TO PARTNER WITH YOU ON THIS?
AND WE DEBATED THIS IS AT OUR
BOARD THIS YEAR.
AS A HEALTH FOUNDATION
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
FEDERAL RESOURCES ABOUT I
CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY THE BOARD
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S NOTHING
MORE IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE'S
HEALTH THEN THEIR SENSE OF
AGENCY OR BELONGING.
HOW WE ACTUALLY WENT TO THE
DICTIONARY AND LOOK TO THE WORD
COUNT?
AND YOU SEE THINGS LIKE
ASSIGNING WORTH OR DESERVING OF
CONSIDERATION.
AND THE OPPOSITE ACCOUNT ARE YOU
FIND WORDS LIKE TO EXCLUDE
ACCOUNT HOW.
SO WHEN WE DISCUSSED THIS AS OUR
SENIOR LEADERSHIP AND BOARD THE
THOUGHT OF FOURTEEN MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FOURTEEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. BEING
COUNTED OUT.
POSES A VERY SERIOUS THREAT TO
THE HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND TO THE.
A HEALTH OF OUR STATE.
I'M JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF FLAVOR OF THAT THERE
FOLKS HERE WITH MORE EXPERTISE
THAN I HAVE. BITE PARA MILLION
OF THOSE AT RISK FOR BEING UNDER
COUNTED ARE BLACK CALIFORNIANS
FIVE MILLION ARE LATINO TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND NATIVE
AMERICANS.
SO HAD THESE ARE OBVIOUSLY.
POPULATIONS WHO ARE AT HIGH RISK
FOR DISPARATE HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND POPULATIONS THAT WE HAVE TO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT.
I'M.
I WANTED TO SAY THAT I'M GLAD
MEMBERS EARLIER MENTIONED THE
ACA UNCOVERED CALIFORNIA EFFORT
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT THERE ARE
SOME PARALLELS. THERE THAT
REALLY YOU CAN'T FIND IN
PREVIOUS CENSUS.
FRANKLY IN PREVIOUS CENSUS WE
HAD OVER PERCEIVED A GOOD FAITH
PARTNERS IN DC.
BUT WHEN THE ACA LAUNCHED IN
CALIFORNIA IT WAS VERY TOXIC
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT HAND
YOU'LL REMEMBER THE DEATH PANELS.
AND OTHER NEGATIVITY SO WE HAD
TO OVERCOME A LOT OF THAT EVEN
HEARING CALIFORNIA AMONG PEOPLES
PERCEPTIONS. AND IT WAS IT TOOK
A HERCULEAN EFFORT THE ENDOWMENT
ALONE SPEND A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ARE OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION. TO COUNTER SOME OF
THAT NEGATIVITY AND GET PEOPLE
TO SIGN UP AND FOR THE MOST PART
IT WAS A SUCCESSFUL EFFORT.
I'M BUT I DID LIKE YOUR QUESTION
EARLIER MISTER JONES SAWYER
ABOUT WHAT DIDN'T WORK.
AND SO I WAS THINKING ABOUT THAT
IN TERMS OF THE ACA. AS WELL AND
A COUPLE OF THINGS CAME TO MIND
YOU KNOW WE WERE VERY EXCITED AT
THE LAUNCH OF THAT EFFORT. THAT
WE COULDN'T CONVINCE DR OZ TO
MAKE IT OUT FOR US.
AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T ALL THE
MESSAGE TESTING TYPE PERSUASIVE
MESSAGES MESSENGERS AND HE WAS
OFF THE CHARTS AT THAT TIME.
AND DO YOU KNOW HE TO HIS
CREDIT HE FLEW OUT HAD NEVER
TAKEN A POSITION ON THE AC TO
THAT POINT. HE MADE THE AD. ABA
WHAT WE DISCOVERED OVER THE
COURSE OF THAT EFFORT IS THAT
THERE WERE THINGS WERE FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE FOR EXAMPLE THE MULTI
ETHNIC MEDIA INVESTMENTS WE MADE.
PRODUCED MORE AND SOME
UNCONVENTIONAL THINGS TO GO TO
SOME QUESTIONS EARLIER. IN THE
WEEK THAT THE MONEY WE PUT INTO
BARBERSHOP NETWORKS THE NUMBER
OF THE DOLLARS THAT WE PUT INTO.
A WRESTLER'S ASSOCIATION
ON YOU TUBE AND GIVES A VERY
UNCONVENTIONAL THINGS ENDED UP
DELIVERING SOME SURPRISING
RESULTS.
HOW AM I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT?
I'M BLESSING ALL MENTIONED AND I
THINK YOU'RE SO WISE TO HAVE HAD
DIRECTOR BROUGH HERE I LEARNED A
LOT HAVE DIRECTOR FROM HEARING
THE HISTORY.
BUT WHAT REALLY STOOD OUT FOR ME
WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AND HOW THAT HASN'T
CHANGED OVER THE DECADES. AND SO
I'M HONORED TO BE SURROUNDED
HEREBY TODAY'S TRUSTED
MESSENGERS.
VETERANS OF THEM A CALL
THEMSELVES THE BOBBY SEALE OF
TODAY. BUT THEY ARE THE FOLKS
WHO COMMUNITIES TRUST.
AND ONE OF THE MAIN LESSONS
FROM RACF AT EFFORT WAS THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS IN THE IN PERSON.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS IS
REALLY WHAT DESERT DELIVERED
THAT THE RESULTS WE BELIEVE THAT
WILL BE THE CASE AGAIN.
AND WE STAND READY TO BE
PARTNERS WITH THE STATE OF AYE
GOOD I WANNA REMIND YOU THAT
MUCH LESSON FROM A CA WAS WHEN
THE STATE STEPPED UP AND SHOW
THAT YOU'RE SERIOUS. AND WOULD
MAKE A ROBUST INVESTMENT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT BROUGHT PLAN TO BE A
LONG.
THANK YOU.
MR DOT ORG.
THE MORNING.
CHAIRMAN BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY
AND FOR YOUR INTEREST IN
ASSURING THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES WHAT IT CAN.
TO ACHIEVE A FAIR AND ACCURATE
COUNT OF OUR STATE POPULATION IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS. MY
NAME IS JOHN DOE BARGAIN ON THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
POLITICAL VOICE PROGRAM AT AT
VASSAR PROJECT CALIFORNIA. WHICH
IS A MULTI RACIAL CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
ALONGSIDE COMMUNITY PARTNERS
TO TRANSFORM PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
AND SHIFT INVESTMENTS TO ACHIEVE
RACIAL EQUITY.
I'M HERE TODAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF IT OF EVENTS
APPROACH CALIFORNIA AND THE
CENSUS POLICY ADVOCACY NETWORK
OR SEE PAN.
SEE PAN IS A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT AMONG MULTIPLE
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO EDUCATE.
POLICY MAKERS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS ABOUT THE.
SOUND POLICIES AND GOVERNMENT
INVESTMENTS NEEDED.
FOR A A COMPLETE DEL OF OUR
STATE.
WHERE DIVERSE COALITION OF
GROUPS OF THE HAS DEEP
EXPERIENCE?
WORKING WITH HARD TO COUNT
POPULATIONS IN OUR STATE.
SUCH AS AFRICAN AMERICANS ASIAN
AMERICANS LATINOS NATIVE
AMERICANS PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
LGBTQ PEOPLE AMERICAN MUSLIMS
OF PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
CHILDREN IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
EYES OTHERS SPEAKERS HAVE
MENTIONED THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS WILL BE UNLIKE ANY OTHER
IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY. AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FACES
MANY CHALLENGES AND TRYING TO
ACHIEVE OF A AN ACCURATE COUNT.
ACHIEVING THAT COUNT.
AND OVERCOMING THOSE THOSE
CHALLENGES IS GONNA REQUIRED
THAT WE BUILD A ROBUST OUTREACH
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT WE TAKE A MULTI SECTOR
APPROACH
TO.
ENCOURAGING AND EDUCATING
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY.
WHAT'S THE PENT ESTIMATES HIS IS
A MINIMUM OF FOURTEEN POINT
SEVEN MILLION HARD TO COUNT
CALIFORNIANS ENCOURAGING IN
EDUCATING THEM TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE SENSE THAT.
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OF CBO'S ARE GONNA PLAY A VITAL
ROLE. IN THAT MULTI SECTOR
EFFORT. AND THAT ROLE WILL BE TO
SERVE AS TRUSTED MESSAGES.
AS.
TRUSTED MESSENGERS CBO'S WILL.
ONE.
EDUCATE COMMUTER RESIDENTS
ABOUT THE CENSUS TO VALIDATE
CENSUS RELATED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
A THREE ASSIST COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS AND UNDERSTANDING THE
QUESTIONNAIRE AND FOR OVERALL
ALLEVIATE ANXIETY ABOUT
RESPONDING TO THE QUESTIONNAIRE.
OR CENSUS BUREAU ENUMERATORS.
SEALS WILL DO THIS YOU TARGETED
OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS THAT WILL OUR
THAT IS. CAMPAIGNS ARE GOING TO
BE IN VERY SPECIFIC GEOGRAPHIES
TARGETING VERY SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS.
AND THEY WILL RECEIVE
POPULATIONS THROUGH VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS DOOR TO DOOR
CANVASSING A DIGITAL CAMPAIGNS
TO TWO SMARTPHONES SOCIAL MEDIA
MESSAGES.
DESERVING OF LOCATIONS AND AND
AND STAFFING FOR ASSISTANCE
CENTERS OR KIOSKS.
.
TRAIL.
MATERIAL DEVELOPMENT IN
LANGUAGE.
AND.
TRAIN THE TRAINER ACTIVITY SO
MULTIPLE ACTIVITIES THAT THAT
CBO WILL BE ENGAGED IN. ARE THE
SEE THE CBO CAMPAIGNS WILL NOT
ONLY ALLEVIATE ANXIETY ABOUT THE
CENSUS AMONG HARD TO COUNT
RESIDENTS. THEY ALSO ENABLE
COUNTIES AND CITIES TO BE MORE
STRATEGIC ABOUT THEIR OWN
OUTREACH.
WHERE CBO THE NONPROFIT
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR PRESIDENT AND
WILL RESOURCE?
TO DO OUTREACH COUNTIES AND
CITIES.
POTENTIALLY HAVE LEFT TO DO AND
CAN DIRECT A MORE INTENSIVE
AGENCY OUTREACH TO AREAS WERE
SUCH ORGANIZATIONS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE DON'T EXIST.
THIS TYPE OF COORDINATED
APPROACH IS ALREADY UNDERWAY IN
LA COUNTY AND WE HOPE TO SEE
MORE OF IT IN OTHER AREAS OF THE
STATE. OF SUCH AN APPROACH IS
THE BEST WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
OVERCOME THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE IN THE SOME PRESIDENT IT'S
IT'S IT'S SENSELESS.
AND RECEIVE THE THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IN CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATION WE DESERVE.
THANK YOU AND OF THE FOUR TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS GUERRA.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN BERMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE. I'M ANDREA
GET IT ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ALLIANCE SAN DIEGO. A
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT
ORGANIZATION.
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WORKING TO
CREATE A MORE INCLUSIVE.
DEMOCRACY AND PART OF THE WAY
THAT WE DO THAT IS MAKING SURE
THAT EVERYONE FEELS COUNTED.
SAN DIEGO AS YOU MAY KNOW IS THE
SECOND LARGEST COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S A SECOND LARGEST
ELECTORATE IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S
ALSO THE SECOND LARGEST HARD TO
COUNT AREA IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A DIVERSE AREA.
I THAT INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
REFUGEES AND AS WELL AS
IMMIGRANTS THERE ARE MORE THAN
ONE HUNDRED LANGUAGES SPOKEN WE
ARE THE LARGEST REFUGEE
RESETTLEMENT COUNTY IN THE
COUNTRY.
WE ALSO HAVE THE THE DUBIOUS.
DISTINCTION OF BEING THE LARGEST
COUNTY HURT THAT WHERE THE A
COUNTY THAT SAW THE LARGEST DROP.
IN THE EMAIL PARTICIPATION RATE.
BETWEEN TWENTY TEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SUBTLE LARGEST DROP
IN PARTICIPATION BETWEEN.
TWO THOUSAND AND AT SITE TWENTY
TEN AND TWENTY TWENTY.
CLUBS UP HAVE HAVE DO WELL ON IT
YET BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
AND TWENTY TEN GOING TO BRING IT
UP TWENTY TWENTY. YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT WE DO WANT TO
BRING IT UP OF WHICH IS WHY IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU'RE ALLOCATING RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE. THAT SAN DIEGO WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS ITS
FAIR SHARE. A WE KNOW THAT THERE
WAS A CONCENTRATION OF EFFORT.
LAST DROWNED IN THE BAY AREA AND
IN LOS ANGELES AND RIGHTLY SO
BUT WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT SAN
DIEGO IS IS NOT FORGOTTEN IN THE
EQUATION BECAUSE AS YOU RIGHTLY
POINTED OUT. TURN BERMAN THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT IS
SIGNIFICANT AND WE DON'T WANNA.
WE DON'T WANNA CUT OUR OF OUR
INVESTMENT SHORE IN SAN DIEGO.
SO SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE FACED IN SAN DIEGO IN IN
THE CONDUCTING A CENSUS AND.
TWENTY TEN WAS DOES THE
CHALLENGE OF THE FEAR. FACED BY
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN SAN
DIEGO AS IN CALIFORNIA ONE IN
FOUR.
RESIDENTS
ARE ESTIMATED TO BE FOREIGN BORN
IMMIGRANTS
AND THEY OFTEN LIVE IN MIXED
STATUS FAMILIES I AM AMONG THOSE.
AS THOSE FAMILIES INCLUDE
CITIZENS LEGAL RESIDENTS AND
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS WHEN
YOU HAVE A MIXED STATUS FAMILIES
YOU ARE VERY HESITANT.
TO DISCLOSE WHO'S IN YOUR HOUSE.
AND THEN THERE'S ALSO FEAR ABOUT
CONFIDENTIALITY HOW THE
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE USED
THAT EXTENDS BEYOND THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY. TO THE
FLOOR BOTHERED FORMERLY
INCARCERATED COMMITTEE TO THE
HOMELESS COMMUNITY AND OTHERS.
AND SO WE WE KNOW THAT THESE
CHALLENGES ARE GOING TO BE
EXACERBATED GOING INTO TWENTY
TWENTY WITH THE RHETORIC FROM
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
SO WHAT DID WE DO IN TWENTY
TRENT TEN THAT WE THOUGHT WORKED
WELL WE DID GET RESOURCES FROM
CALIFORNIAN DOWNMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND WE WERE ABLE TO
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO ROUGHLY
SIXTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
AREA.
TO ENCOURAGE THEIR PARTICIPATION
THESE WARRANTS IN HARD TO COUNT
AREAS OF OUR COUNTY. A WE ALSO
RAN BUS ADS AND I WON THE LIFT
THAT UP BECAUSE BUS ADS THROUGH.
HIGH DENSITY AREAS WITH HARD TO
COUNT POPULATIONS WAS A GREAT
WAY TO ELEVATE THE AWARENESS.
A IN THE POPULATION NOW IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO SPEND OUR MONEY
TO DO THAT OR YOUR MONEY AS A
WATER. OF BUT IT'S IT WE HAD
STATE RESOURCES OR LOCAL
RESOURCES TO PAY FOR THOSE SORTS
OF ACTIVITIES. THAT WOULD BE
GRANT.
A IN AND SO WE WERE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE IN DOING OUR OUTREACH
TO THE COMMUNITY AND THAT WAS
BECAUSE OF ONE REASON AND ONE
REASON ONLY AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE HAVE A RELATIONSHIP OF TRUST
WITH A COMMUNITY. THAT'S BEEN
SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN HERE
BUT OUR ORGANIZATION AND OTHERS
LIKE OURS. WE ARE VALUE ADDED IN
THIS EQUATION IS THE
RELATIONSHIP OF TRUST THAT WE
HAVE. AND SO IT'S GOING TO BE
CRITICAL TO PARTNER WITH US
EARLY AS EARLY AS YOU CAN.
BUT I DO WANT TO MENTION THAT
THE RESOURCES IN SAN DIEGO. WERE
NOT ENOUGH OF WE.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
CONCERTED EFFORT.
TO GET A COMPLETE COUNT BUT AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE OF WE HAD THE
LARGEST DROP IN PARTICIPATION
FROM ONE CENSUS TO THE NEXT. AND
SO IF YOU ASK ME WHAT YOU SHOULD
DO GOING FORWARD I WOULD SAY
WHICH ALREADY DOING AND AND THAT
IS TO START EARLY.
INVEST MORE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH TRUSTED PARTNERS.
IN ALL OF THE HARD TO COUNT
AREAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIN UP.
OUR THANK CHAIRMAN.
INDISTINCT MEMBERS OF BOTH
COMMITTEES.
MY NAME IS THAT YOU KNOW SAYING
AND I DIRECT THE DEMOGRAPHIC
RESEARCH PROJECT AND SINCE
INFORMATION CENTER EDITION
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS
ANGELES OF THE NATION'S LARGEST.
LEGAL AND CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS SERVING ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
FOUNDED NEARLY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO I ADVANCING JUSTICE IS
HELP LEAD DECENNIAL CENSUS
OUTREACH EFFORTS TARGETING OUR
COMMUNITIES. ON SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY ON SERVING AS A HUB FOR A
STATEWIDE NETWORK OF FIVE.
DIVERSE COMMUNITY PARTNERS I'M
WORKING TO ENCOURAGE RESPONSE
DURING THE NIGHT THE IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TEN CENTS.
OF THE DECENNIAL CENSUS IS
IMPORTANT TO ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN WAYS THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT ALL CALIFORNIANS
I'M IT'S CRITICAL TO FOUR OUT TO
OUR POLITICAL PARTICIPATION.
AND OUR FAIR SHARE FEDERAL
STATE.
AND LOCAL FUNDS ARM FOR
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS OURS
EXPERIENCING RAPID GROWTH ARMS
AS IF THEY ARE ALSO IMPORTANT
TOOL TO ENSURE. ON THAT PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE PROGRAMS BOTH
UNDERSTAND.
AND ARE RESPONSIVE TO UP OUR
DIVERSE POPULATIONS
I'M ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
CENSUS BUREAU ESTIMATES THERE
OVER SIX POINT SIX MILLION I'M
ASIAN AMERICANS AND NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS ARE STATEWIDE.
UNTIL HOPE NO STATE IS HOME TO
MORE ASIAN AMERICANS.
AND ONLY THE STATE OF HAWAII IS
HOME TO MORE PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
ON THESE LARGE POPULATIONS ARE
CALIFORNIA'S FASTEST GROWING ON
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND TEN
CENSUS UMNO COMMUNITIES HAVE
GROWN FASTER.
THAT GROWTH IS BEING DRIVEN BY
IMMIGRATION ARM APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY PERCENT OF ASIAN AMERICANS.
I'M SIX ZERO ARE IN TWENTY
PERCENT OF PACIFIC ISLANDERS ARE
FOREIGN BORN SO NO COMMUNITIES
PROPORTIONALLY ARE MORE FOREIGN
BORN THE NATION AMERICANS.
I'M ARE OVERWHELMINGLY IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
ARE ETHNICALLY CULTURALLY.
AND LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE
FACING CHALLENGES.
WITH LANGUAGE BARRIERS SO ALL
THIS MAKES OUR COMMUNITIES.
HARD TO COUNT.
ON TO ENSURE COMPLETE COUNT OF
AYE ASIAN AMERICANS PACIFIC
ISLANDERS OF STATEWIDE WE NEED
TO DO THINGS LIKE A ONE
DEVELOPMENT TEST MESSAGES I'M
RECOGNIZING THAT NO ONE MESSAGE.
WILL WORK FOR ALL OUR
COMMUNITIES ONTO DEVELOPING
TRANSLATE OUT WHICH MATERIALS
AND PSAS WHAT WE KNOW WILL BE
CRITICAL TO ENGAGING OUR
COMMUNITIES. ARE MEANT THREE SUB
GRANT TO AND TRAIN.
CAMILLE ORGANIZATIONS WHO WILL
ENGAGE COMMUNITIES AS TRUSTED
MESSENGERS AS FOLKS HAVE FUN
IDENTIFIED. ON BUT MOST
CRITICALLY ALL OF THIS IS TO BE
DONE.
IN DOZENS OF ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER LANGUAGES AND I WANT TO
FLAG FOR BOTH COMMITTEES ON THAT
THE CENSUS BUREAU CURRENTLY DOES
NOT HAVE PLANS ON TO PRODUCE ANY
TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS OUR
RESOURCES IN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LANGUAGES SO THAT ZERO. AND WE
KNOW THAT THE PACIFIC ON A
COMMUNITY WAS ONE OF THE HARDEST
COUNTY TWENTY TEN.
ENCLOSING Y. WE BELIEVE THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE PARTNERSHIPS ARE
CRITICAL.
TO THE SUCCESS OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS ARM WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY I'M OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY.
NOT BEHIND A DESK DEALING WITH
BURDEN SOME ARE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
BUT COUNT ABILITY IS NOTHING
NEW TO THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN
DOING THIS WORK.
CLEARING QUANTIFIABLE
DELIVERABLES ARE IMPORTANT OF
PROPHECIES FOR INFORMATION
GATHERING THAT ALLOW FOR SHIPS
IN THE WORK.
TO ADDRESS CHANGING CONDITIONS
IN EMERGING AYE ISSUES ARE
IMPORTANT ON STRUCTURING SUB
GRANTING TO COMMITTEE PARTNERS
ARM IN INSTALLMENTS MAINTAINS
ENGAGEMENT. ARMS SO THANKS SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU THIS MORNING AND
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE ON WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
TO COUNT EVERY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I ANY QUESTIONS FROM FROM
COLLEAGUES SO I GUESS. SO THEY
ARE CBO THEN A PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITY ARE GONNA BE SO
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
SIX
IN THIS EFFORT NOW HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS.
WITH THE PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITY AND AND WE'LL HAVE
MORE. LATER TODAY.
WHITE AND AND RESEARCH YOU KNOW
SAY YOU KNOW YOU YOU RIGHTFULLY.
MENTION THE IMPORTANCE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY BUT NOT TO OVER
THE OWNERS REGULATION.
WHAT?
YEAH I GUESS IT DIDN'T ME THIS
IS AN UNFAIR QUESTION ASKED
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY. TO IT TO
ENSURE THAT AND EIGHT GIVEN THAT
THIS CAN BE MONEY BEING SPENT BY
THE PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY
WHICH HISTORICALLY HAS.
RELATIONSHIPS WITH WITH
DIFFERENT CBO'S IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THEN.
THE STATE GOVERNMENT'S GONNA BE
SPENDING MORE THAN WE EVER HAVE
BEFORE.
ON OUTREACH AND COMMUNICATION
EFFORT AND KEY INCLUDING FUNDING
LOCAL EFFORTS THROUGH CBO'S.
DO YOU WHAT WOULD YOU AND IF
YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS ON WHAT THE
BEST WAY IS TO TO EXECUTE ON
THAT MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THE
MONEY SPENT EFFECTIVELY.
ONE ONE IMPORTANT PIECE WILL BE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE CBO PIECE
WHICH. SOUGHT TO THOUSAND THE
STATE CONTRACT WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE CBO THAT THEN
SUBCONTRACTING TO LOCAL FEELS
COUSIN AND DOES ADMINISTRATIVE
CBO'S HAD. HOPPED ON A LARGE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MONITORING.
WHAT THE LOCAL CBO THEY'RE
DOING AND ALSO DISTRIBUTING THEM
THE MONEY SO?
FORT TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
CERTAINLY ONE WAY TO ENSURE.
THAT'S A GOOD.
GIVEN THE SCALE AND THE AMOUNT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE NUMBER OF IT ADMINISTRATIVE
CBO'S WOULD NEED TO BE LARGER
BUT ARE JUST HAVING THOSE IN
PLACE WOULD BE ONE KEY PIECE
JOHN.
MASON THAT'S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT I THINK FOR ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES MANY OF.
OUR.
PARTNERS WHO WE CAN WORK ON THE
GROUND OR SMALLER RIGHT I MEAN
HE'S A SMALLER ORGANIZATION
SERVING SMALLER COMMUNITIES BUT
REALLY CRITICAL VOICES IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES. I'M SO HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT OF YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THINGS LIKE CLEAR
DELIVERABLES QUANTIFIABLE
DELIVERABLES.
BUT ALSO NOT.
ONEROUS REPORTING
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT DOWN THAT
THESE OR THE SMALLER
ORGANIZATIONS MAYBE I.
CHALLENGED THEIR WITH SO.
I DON'T KNOW IT WAS DEVELOPMENT
ORDER FOR NONPROFIT WE JUST
DIDN'T BOTHER TRYING TO GET
GOVERNMENT GRANTS.
BECAUSE THEY THE APPLICATION
PROCESS WAS SO. AND WE'LL THE
CHAIR THERE.
YEAH AND I THINK YOU CAN ALSO
LOOK TO LARRY NON TO EXISTING
GRANT STRUCTURES THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE FOR EXAMPLE TO THE
ONE CALIFORNIA GRANT PROCESS.
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THERE IS ALREADY A TAPESTRY OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE GETTING
GRANT FUNDING TO DO IMMIGRANT
OUTREACH YEAH AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE HARDEST.
COMMUNITIES TO REACH AND SO I
AND THAT'S ALSO A MODEL FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S LESS
ONEROUS AND SOME OF THE OTHER
GRANT STRUCTURES THAT THE STATE
HAS. A MIGHT THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING TO LOOK WHAT ABOUT THIS.
.
DON'T GET CARRIED AWAY.
YEAH EVALUATION PIECE.
WERE EXAGGERATE HOW RELIABLE
YOU REALLY THINK THAT IS BUT
WELL OUR CONFIDENCE HAS BOOSTED
BY THE FACT THAT YOU ALL HAVE
SOME OF MY DDS AND DANIEL AND
OTHERS WHO. HAVE A HISTORY OF
EXPERIENCE AND THEY KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF COURSE CORRECTING
AS YOU GO THEY KNOW THAT THE.
VALUE OF OF KEEPING COUNT YOU
CAN ACTUALLY WATCH IN REAL TIME
WHERE THINGS ARE SUCCEEDING IN
NOT MAKE COURSE CORRECTIONS BUT.
AGAIN JUST AYE MY ADVICE TO YOU
FROM COMING FROM OUR SECTOR IS.
DON'T DON'T GET TOO OBSESSIVE
ABOUT SARAH PUTTING THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGH LOTS OF A
FORMAL EVALUATIONS AND CONSTANT.
REPORTING BECAUSE THEN THAT
TAKES AWAY FROM ACTUALLY GETTING
THE JOB DONE SIR GUN DEFEATS THE
PURPOSE HIM.
WILL THINK ANYTHING ELSE THAT
YOU THAT YOU THINK WE SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT.
AT THIS STAGE I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA BE HAVING LOTS OF
CONVERSATION TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE DO GET THE
RESOURCES TO TO DISTRIBUTE
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDED ON THE
SAN DIEGO.
SAN DIEGO HAS SOME PRETTY.
PRETTY PRETTY GET.
REPRESENTATIVES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT ARE GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT HAPPENS.
YES. THEY WILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
IT'S A WIN TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
AND WE DIDN'T.
DO A SIGN IN SHEET SO IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT JUST
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE IN
THE MIDDLE IF YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO ABOUT ONE MINUTE PER
PERSON THAT WOULD BE VERY
APPRECIATED.
AS WE GET BACK ON TRACK.
IF YOU TO SAY.
YOUR NAME AND IF YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AN ORGANIZATION
WOULD ORGANIZATION I REGRET.
HI MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AYE
JULIE SNYDER REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE ARE A
MEMBER OF CP ON THE CENSUS
POLICY ADVANCEMENT NETWORK OR
ADVOCACY NETWORK SORRY AS WELL
AS THE CALIFORNIA COMPLETE COUNT
COMMITTEE. THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT EFFORT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE THE NUMBER
OF THE PEOPLE WE SERVE ARE AMONG
THE HARDEST TO COUNT SO FOR
EXAMPLE PEOPLE WITHOUT A FIXED
ADDRESS. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
SENDING A POSTCARD.
DOES NOT NECESSARILY REACH THEM
SENDING A SECOND POSTCARD IS NOT
GOING TO REACH THEM SO.
WE'RE INVOLVED IN THIS EFFORT
I'M TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
FOLKS ARE COUNTED IN CALIFORNIA
HAS THE HIGHEST HOMELESS
POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT'S
RECOGNIZED. AS WELL WE SERVE A
NUMBER OF RESIDENTS OF FOR WHOM
ENGLISH IS A SECOND LANGUAGE WHO
ALSO COME FROM COUNTRIES AS
REFUGEES WHERE THE GOVERNMENT IS
NOT HIGHLY TRUSTED. AND SO AGAIN
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO BE PART OF
THIS EFFORT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY IS COUNTED.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE POUNDS
BUDGET REQUEST AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO ANGELINA ASIAN AMERICANS
VETTING JUST CALIFORNIA ALSO
MEMBERS SEE PAN AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF.
A BUDGET REQUESTS THAT WE'RE
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE GOVERNOR
FORMER VICE A PROPOSAL FOR
JANUARY BUT WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF ASSISTIVE
QUESTION. A LOT OF FEARS WITH
THE NUMBERS AND COMMITTEE ABOUT
A MONTH AND REGISTRY I'M REALLY
PUSHING FOR INCREASED AFTER THAT
A TWELVE POINT FIVE MILLION. FOR
CBO FUNDING TO GO TWO HUNDRED
SEVEN MILLION WHICH ON ABOUT
NINETY TWO ORGANIZATIONS FOR US
IN SUPPORT OF THE REQUESTS OF.
THE FOR THAT ROBUST DISCUSSION
ABOUT TRUST MESSAGES BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT WE REALLY VITAL FOR
COMPLETE COUNT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
AS A.
PLEASE HAND CENSUS TWO POINT TWO
MILLION CHILDREN WERE
UNDERCOUNTED SO WE WANT TO
STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF. AND
FAMILIES.
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN WHO HAVE
ADDITIONAL STRESSES.
AT THAT THE OUTREACH AND
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT EVERY
CHILD EVERY INFANT IS COUNTED
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST TO HAVE THAT YOU CAN
HAVE ME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
I'M CENTER CERAM SANTANA
REPRESENTING CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE ARE A
COMMUNITY BASED.
DOWN AND SINCE OUR FOUNDING IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE WE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN EVERY DECENNIAL
CENSUS FOR THE PAST FIVE DECADES.
SO THAT EXPERIENCE HAS TAUGHT US
A LOT AND ONE MAIN THING IS THAT
CENSUS TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT WILL
BE WON OR LOST AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. SO IT'S REALLY KEY THAT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
BEFRIENDED ROBUSTLY TO DO THIS
WORK AND THAT THERE IS A
LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN FOR THE
HARD TO REACH THAT PRIORITISES
ARE LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
POPULATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN MICHAEL RIGHT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS HEARING IT WAS VERY
VERY HELPFUL.
AND INDICATE AS YOU KNOW THE
COUNTY'S COMMITMENT TO THIS
EFFORT IN FACT.
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS
COMMITTED A MILLION DOLLARS OF
THEIR GENERAL FUND THIS YEAR TO.
THE EFFORT WITH OBVIOUSLY MORE
COMING IN THE FOLLOWING YEARS.
SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE.
LEGISLATURE CONCEDE INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY AVAILABLE BE
ON THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST WOULD
BE MOST APPRECIATED AND WE'RE
GONNA BE FOLLOWING ALL FOR THE
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JOE MICHAEL VERY
QUALITY CALIFORNIA WHERE ALSO A
MEMBER OF SEE PAN AND WANT TO
STATE OUR SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
SUBMITTED.
AND ALSO JUST STATE IT DIED OUT
YOU TAKE YOU PEOPLE ARE PART OF
ALL OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
BEING COUNTED AND ALTHOUGH LGBTQ
PEOPLE ARE ONLY BEING COUNTED IN
A LIMITED WAY IN THE CENSUS. AYE
WE DEFINITELY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COMMUNITY REPRESENTED
AND AND THAT FOLKS ARE AYE
ENGAGING WITH THE CENSUS SO
THAT'S PART OF HOW WE SEE OUR
INVOLVEMENT IN THE OUTREACH
EFFORTS AND. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE COUNT IS AS COMPLETE AS
POSSIBLE FOR EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME TO HEAR EVERYONE
TODAY. THANK YOU.
I INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA ONE
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THE PAN
AND THEN BUDGET REQUEST AND
ENCOURAGE ROBUST INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WERE TRUSTED MESSENGERS TO DO
THIS CRITICAL SENSES THAT REACH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WATCHING.
NO I BOTTOM ALL CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
SERVE LOW INCOME MARGINALIZE
DISADVANTAGED FARM WORKER
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
PARTICULARLY IN A CENTRAL VALLEY.
THIS IS A RICH CONVERSATION
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PRESENTERS
TODAY. LEARNED A LOT.
SURELY FOUNDATION PARTICULAR
FRESNO OFFICE ATTENDED THE
FRESNO REGIONAL CONVENING ALMOND
MODESTO SO I'LL BE ATTENDING
THAT ONE. THERE STANISLAUS
COUNTY BUT A COUPLE OF TAKE
AWAYS WE HAD FROM THE REGIONAL
CONVENIENT AND ALSO LEARNING
TODAY. IS THAT YOU ARE CENTRAL
VALLEY REGION THAT WHERE WE HAVE
FARMWORKERS WE HAVE ALL OUR
ISSUES THERE IT'S A VAST AREA WE
HAVE GEOGRAPHIC ISOLATION
LANGUAGE ACCESS ISSUES. IS THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED ACCURATE
VERIFIABLE INFORMATION.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE CONFIDENTIAL
PRIVACY RIGHTS ARE SECURED. WE
NEED TO HAVE THE UNIFORM
MESSAGING THAT HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY.
PARTICULARLY AS WE LOOK AT LACK
OF INTERNET ACCESS AND ALSO THE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS.
SPECIFICALLY WE NEED MORE VERIFY
VERIFIABLE INFORMATION ADVICE
AND GUIDANCE REGARDING LEGAL
RIGHTS OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
RESIDENTS ARE ASKING FOR THAT
INFORMATION. UP ALL THROUGH THIS
PERIOD RIGHT NOW AND LEADING UP
TO WHEN A SENSE OF WILL HAPPEN
SO WE'RE GONNA NEED THAT
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THOSE ON
THE GROUND.
AND ALSO.
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA DO TO HELP US
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES?
WITH REGARDS TO QUESTIONS AND
THE APPARATUS THAT'S PUT IN
PLACE.
AND THEN FINALLY.
WE NEED TO ALSO BE SURE TO
SYNCHRONIZE A CITY COUNTY. AND
THE STATE'S EFFORTS AS WE GO
FORWARD OUT THEIR PARTICULAR
CONCERNS THAT. IF WE DON'T DO DO
THAT THEY WILL MISS OUT ON OUR
CUT COMMUNITIES BEING COUNTED.
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY A COUPLE OF TOWNS
AND CITIES HAVE A.
SUPPORTED THE SO CALLED CENTURY
CITY LAWSUIT THAT THAT'S ALREADY
CREATING A BARRIER GETS HOW ARE
RESIDENTS A HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES LANGUAGE ISOLATED.
COMMITTEE IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
TRUST THAT CITY SO THE CITIES
NEED TO KNOW NOT ONLY TO WORK ON
THE COUNT. BUT ALSO WE NEED TO
WORK WITH THEM TO ADDRESS THAT
THEY NEED TO ALSO BE PART OF
THIS SOLUTION TO GET OUR.
RESIDENCIES LEGAL ADVICE AND
GUIDANCE THAT THEY DESERVE SO
ALL THIS TAKEN ACCOUNT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING WE'RE
GONNA NEED.
FOR A OUTREACH AND EDUCATION TO
REACH OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEVEN KEPPEL.
REPRESENTING UNIVISION.
MORE HERE ON BEHALF OF OUR
HISPANIC AUDIENCES PARTICULARLY
THE SPANISH SPEAKERS AND AND THE
FIVE MILLION.
LATINO CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE IN
HARD TO COUNT COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE ARE.
MEMBERS OF THE CORPS UNIVISION
AUDIENCE AND CONSUMERS OF OTHERS
BEING THE SPANISH LANGUAGE MEDIA.
SO WE KNOW THAT THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AS HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO HELP LEAD OUR ECA
OUT OUTREACH EFFORTS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO TWENTY FOURTEEN.
REITERATING SOME OF WHAT WAS
SAID BEFORE I THINK SOME OF THE.
KEY REASONS THAT WORKED WELL WAS
THE COMBINATION OF PHILANTHROPY
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY THE
CALIFORNIA NOW MEANT.
THE STATE COVERED CALIFORNIA WAS
A BIG PARTNER.
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS AND CBO'S
WERE KEY TO THE EFFORT BUT AS
WELL AS MEDIA WE HAD A GREAT
MEDIA COALITION OF SPANISH
LANGUAGE MEDIA GROUPS TV RADIO.
NAM PRINT AND EVERYTHING WE
THINK THAT'S THAT'S IMPORTANT.
TWO BIG THINGS ARE NEEDED FOR
THIS I THINK OUR TIME MAKE SURE
ENOUGH TIME TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE.
AND RESOURCES.
SO I'M KIND ON UNIVISION AS A
PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT THINGS
ARE MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
CAROLYN BACKER HERE IN THIS
MOMENT ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN LA IN
SYNC. REPRESENTING AS YOU KNOW
THE SINGLE MOST HARDEST ACCOUNT
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY.
CCF AND LA AND SINK ARE HERE TOO
ALSO ALIGN VOICE ISN'T
SUGGESTING THERE'S A CRITICAL
NEED FOR AUGMENTING FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED OUTREACH.
PHILANTHROPY IS COMMITTED AND
READY AND LOOKS FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH THE STATE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE A
COMPLETE COUNTY TWENTY TWENTY
ESPECIALLY IN THE HARDEST
ACCOUNT COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SAMANTHA SAYING THE
NEXT GEN AMERICA.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
SUPPORT INVESTMENT IN THE
COMPLETE CAO. ALSO A APPRECIATE
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUING SUPPORT
WE ARE HAPPY TO JOIN C. PAN.
AND OR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS ON
THEIR BUDGET ITEM A LETTER.
AND GREATLY.
.
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO CONTINUE
THINKING ALONG INVESTMENT IN
CBO'S IS THERE GOING TO BE KEY
TO COMPLETECAO THINK. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOANNE
FIELDS FROM SAN DIEGO I
REPRESENT THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER INITIATIVE. AND I HAVE
THE UNIQUE EXPERIENCE OF HAVING
WORKED AS A RECRUITING ASSISTED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND ALSO THE
PARTNERSHIP SPECIALIST TO OUT
WHICH THE. NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND ASIAN
COMMUNITIES ALLOW EVERYONE IS
VYING TO SAY THAT THEY ARE THE
HARDEST OUT COUNTY TO COUNT I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PITCH FOR
SAN DIEGO. BEING IN THE BORDER
REGION THAT.
WE WE HAVE THAT CONCERN OF THE
CITIZENSHIP QUESTION HOW MY NO
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP OFTEN BUT
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO BRING THE
CONCERN OF CYBERSECURITY. NOW
THAT WE ARE GOING ON LINE AND
HOW ARE WE ALSO GOING TO ADDRESS
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE DIDN'T
OUT FUND AYE INTERNET RADIO
STATIONS.
BACK THEN BECAUSE THERE WAS A
ANALYTICS AVAILABLE SO THERE
WASN'T MEDIA BIAS BUT I CAN TELL
YOU THAT. I AM INTERNET RADIO
STATIONS LIKE ISLAND BLOCK HAS
ANALYTICS OF FOUR MILLION AND
REACH OUT WE ALSO HAVE SMALLER.
STATIONS.
IN THE LOCAL AREA K. B. L. QUE
THAT HAS A REACH IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SO WHY WE SAY
THAT THERE THERE ARE A LOT OF
CONCERNS BUT I DO WANT TO BRING
ATTENTION TO THAT.
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
ESPECIALLY THE NATIVE HAWAIIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY I
DON'T THINK THE COMMUNITY REALLY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THAT UMBRELLA
AND TAILS. BECAUSE IF I ASK YOU
WOULDN'T SAY HOW WHO IS IN THE
ASIAN COMMUNITY YOU MAY THINK
JAPANESE CHINESE VIETNAMESE MONK.
BUT IF I SAY NATIVE HAWAIIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER ITS WHOLE Y.
AND CHAMORRO.
SOMEONE BUT THAT HUGE UMBRELLA
ALSO INCLUDES FILIPINOS IT I'M
CLUED TONGANS AND SO MANY OTHER
API GROUPS THAT WE GET LOST IN
THE MIX.
AND THEN IF I ASK YOU ABOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT USUALLY
MEANS LA. AND I I WAS BORN IN LA
BUT I AM REYES IN SAN DIEGO
HAVING THE TYPICAL FILIPINO
STORY OF.
MY DAD WAS IN THE NAVY MY MOM'S
A NURSE BUT WHAT WE DON'T FALL
RIGHT AWAY WHEN WE SAY. ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER WE THINK
FILIPINO IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY BUT
ALL THE API GROUPS PUT TOGETHER.
HALF OUR FILIPINO SO WHEN WE
LOOK FOR THE MESSAGING PLEASE
DON'T FORGET THE SMALLER PAPERS
LIKE OUR OLDEST AND LARGEST
PAPER THE FILIPINO PRESS BECAUSE
IT IS VERY HARD WHEN BURKE IT
SEEMS LIKE WE'RE COMPETING. WHEN
IT COMES TO MEDIA DOLLARS AN
OUTREACH
BECAUSE AGAIN.
WE ARE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MEANS
USUALLY MEANS LA MAYBE ORANGE
COUNTY AND THEN THERE SAN DIEGO
AND WE ALSO HAVE THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF INDIAN RESERVATIONS
PEOPLE DON'T THINK THAT.
THAT COMES INTO PLAY SO THERE'S
A LOT THAT GOES ON WE HAVE THE
MARINA AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'D LIKE TO MEET CHRIS
IF SHE'S EN AND DETESTS I WAS
REFERRED TO BY REGINA I NEED TO
MEET THEM. BUT THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING I'M JUDY ROBINSON
THE CENSUS MANAGER FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THIS IS BEEN A
GREAT HEARING THIS MORNING AND.
OUR BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS
ADOPTED A RESOLUTION IN THEIR
FULLY COMMITTED TO GIVING IS
COMPLETE ACCOUNT AS POSSIBLE. ON
THEY ALSO SHARE A CONCERN OF AN
UNDERCOUNT ARE WE WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR AND THE STAFF FOR
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET.
FOR CENSUS FUNDING.
YET SIMILAR TO THE ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
IT'S GOING TO TAKE FUTURE ON AND
VAST RESOURCES THAT CERTAINLY
EXCEED THAT AMOUNT IN.
.
YOU KNOW WERE WERE AND IN NEED
OF THAT LIKE ALL OTHER COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M I WANT TO
COMMEND YOUR STAFF I'M A CHRIS
AND LISA HAVE BEEN WONDERFUL AS
HAS DIEGO SO WE HAD OUR FIRST
CONVENING I'M IN THE REGIONAL
CONVENING WASN'T SACRAMENTO. AND
FRANKLY WITH THE BROAD SPECTRUM
OF COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WERE THERE I WAS PROUD TO
BE A SACRAMENTO IN.
ARE WE GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF PASSIONATE
FOLKS TO DO IT. AND ALSO LIKE TO
REITERATE THAT ACROSS THE
COUNTIES WITH SAN MATEO SANTA
CLARA TO BEGIN WITH DOROTHEA'S
OF IN OF THAT WOULD HAVE. OF A
ROLE MODEL THERE THEY ARE AT THE
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
STARTING TO COLLABORATE WE'VE
GOT SOME REGULAR CALL CENTER SET
UP AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE. CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER SHARE OUR SUCCESSES AND
FAILURES SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
I'M.
LEVERAGE ALL THE RESOURCES THAT
YOU'RE.
GOING TO PROVIDE US WITH ANYWAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS IS
GREAT.
MY NAME IS TINA REYNOLDS WITH
UPTOWN STUDIOS AND WE GOT
INVOLVED EARLY AND. I ALREADY
KNOW.
I COUNT
AND I THINK MANY OF YOU.
WELL WHAT WERE INVOLVED THEN IS
I THINK THAT THIS IS SUCH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BREAK DOWN
BARRIERS IN SILOS AND PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO REALLY START WORKING
TOGETHER IN THIS THE START OF.
MANY OTHER COLLABORATIONS THANK
YOU FOR PUTTING THIS ALL
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU AND THEN YOU THE T.
SHIRTS.
WELL THANK YOU.
I GUESS ALTHOUGH CRITICISM
COMES THEN TURNED OVER TO DOCTOR
PAN.
BY I'M JUST SO HEARTENED BY
EVERY CONVERSATION I HAVE ABOUT
THE CENSUS AND THIS IS YOU KNOW
IS IS THAT IT'S JUST BEEN. A
VERY INFORMATIONAL VERY
EDUCATION ON A TOTAL JOY.
TO HEAR EVERYBODY COMING GET
INVOLVED AND AND OFFER YOUR
INSIGHTS ON WHAT'S WORKED IN THE
PAST AND WHAT HAS AND AND WE
KNOW THAT WHAT WE NEEDED. TRIPLE
DOWN ON THIS YEAR OR YELL AT THE
NEXT TWO YEARS THROUGH THE
CENSUS IN TWENTY TWENTY BECAUSE
THE CHALLENGES GREATER THAN.
IT'S EVER BEENIN THE PAST BUT
IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY FOR THAT THAT I
COUNT THE THAT WAS ON THE TEE
SHIRT YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT
AS AS I I ALWAYS MAKE SURE TO
GIVE MEASURE PUTIAN WHEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL. A HOBBY OF
THIS AREA SAID IF YOU IF YOU'RE
NOT COUNTED YOU DON'T COUNT.
AND EVERY CALIFORNIAN COUNTS
AND SO IT'S AGAIN TO BE.
HECK OF A CHALLENGE I'VE JUST
BEEN VERY HEARTENED BY.
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD I
REMEMBER I WAS MEETING A
GENTLEMAN WHO HAS A FOUNDATION.
IN MY DISTRICT ARE ABOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION ISSUES A TIME WHEN
WE'RE DONE WITH THAT HE SAID
WHAT ELSE YOU WORKING ON AS A
NUMBER JUST BECAME CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE. ON THE CENSUS
AND HE'S A REALLY THAT'S REALLY
INTERESTING I WANT INTRODUCED
YOU TO THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MY
FOUNDATION HE DID AND SHE SAID
WERE ALREADY WORKING ON IT.
AND AND YOU KNOW THAT'S BEEN
THE KIND OF THE CASE WITH SO
MANY CONVERSATIONS I'VE HAD
WHETHER IN THE PHILANTHROPIC
COMMUNITY OR THE CBO COMMUNITY
WHERE YOU ARE ARE ALL WHERE
YOU'VE BEEN PARTICIPANTS IN THE
PAST.
YOU REALIZE THE IMPORTANCE AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO PARTNER
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT THE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY AND THE
CBO NONPROFIT COMMUNITY A TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
COUNTS AND IS COUNTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY AS A REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU ALL PARTICIPATING IN WHAT'S
THE FIRST EVER GOING TO BE MANY
CONVERSATIONS.
A OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS.
AND WE'RE GONNA YOU KNOW IF WE
WORK TOGETHER I'M VERY CONFIDENT
THAT THAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY CALIFORNIANS COUNTED.
I JUST WANT TO THANK OF EVERYONE
FOR BEING HERE AND ALL THE.
THAT WITNESSES WHO CAME TO
TESTIFY SPEAKS OUR SOMEONE A
THANGKA.
AS A MEMBER BERMAN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND ALSO.
ARE LIKE THAT COLLEAGUES WHO
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING THIS
HEARING AND ALSO THE ONES WHO
ARE PHYSICALLY HERE ALSO. AT
BEING GAUGES WHILE THEY KNOW
THEIR STAFF THIS PAYING
ATTENTION AND LISTENING TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE TODAY.
.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE WITH THE CENSUS.
TO REALLY SHOW WHAT CALIFORNIA
VALUES ARE ABOUT WATER
INNOVATION IS ABOUT. AND HOW WE
COME TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY TO
OVERCOME BARRIERS TO SUCCEED.
WE NEED TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
PRIZE OUR DIVERSITY OUR
INNOVATION OUR FORWARD THINKING
S. HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVE THAT TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY.
THROUGH OUR SUCCESS AND BE SURE
EVERYONE COUNTS
IN THE CALIPHATE IN THE U. S.
CENSUS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE WE REALLY TRULY DO
BELIEVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
EVERYONE COUNTS.
AND THAT'S WHY.
I'VE REALLY THRILLED THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER THIS
IS ACTUALLY KIND OF AYE FOR ALL
THOSE OF US ELECTED OFFICE
COMPARED TO A CAMPAIGN YOU START
OUT. YOU KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TWO YEARS IN ADVANCE RIGHT. AND
YOU IDENTIFY YOUR VOTERS AND YOU
GO YOU TURN THEM OUT RIGHT SO
WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU KNOW WE
CALL GEO TV FOR ELECTIONS WORLD
DOTC GET OUT THE COUNT RIGHT. SO
WE'RE GONNA DO THAT COME APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY.
BUT THE LEAD UP TO THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
ORGANIZE PUT TOGETHER I ASSUME I
THINK THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS
WELL.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE ALL NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER HAND IN HAND
COOPERATION AND MAKE SUCCESSFUL
SO AGAIN THIS IS JUST A FIRST
HEARING AIDS WHAT THEY GIVEN
PARTICIPATED. AND I'M LOOKING
FOR TO OUR CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS AND.
EVENTUAL SUCCESS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY SO AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE ABSOLUTELY
IT WOULD BE VERY REMISS IF WE
DIDN'T THINK CHRIS RAGMAN AND AT
LEAST.
CHEETAH FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
YOU ALL DID FOR FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER SO THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH ALSO THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
MEETING ADJOURNED.
HEARING IS ADJOURNED